there are a whole lot of things
happening in the world that are scary
and alarming joe biden says that food
shortages are coming he says that if
vladimir putin used chemical weapons
we'll respond others have said that if
they use nukes the fallout could spread
to europe and then nato be forced to
respond and two
members of the russia russia's nuclear
chain of command have gone radio silent
and people are paranoid but we're not
leading with that story as much as those
stories are important we will talk about
them the one thing i think is
particularly important is that the daily
wires jeremy's razors
in just three days have surpassed
harry's razors and followers the reason
i think this is this is significant
is that what happens here in the united
states culturally will impact us
politically and then we'll have very
serious ramifications joe biden wouldn't
uh would not be president if the right
had a stronger culture or more dominance
in cultural spaces to influence people
which ultimately leads to voting and
practices and for a lot of the problems
that we see from our political class it
has a lot to do with the fact that the
left dominates cultural institutions in
the media and they control it so seeing
a story about
harry's
canceling or denouncing the daily wire
and the the daily wire rebutting and
growing bigger than their own twitter
account in three days five million views
on their commercial in only a few days i
think it's significant and as you know
my opinion on the daily wire is that
what they're doing is absolutely
fantastic and building culture so
joining us to talk about that is
co-ceo of the daily wire jeremy bourne
co-ceo and god king of course yeah sorry
come on yes blasphemy it seems like such
a small ask yeah right exactly yeah and
and and also um
uh member of the the hot duo smokey mic
and the god kingdom mike and the god
king smoking mic good stuff yeah you
know
the thing about smokey mike and the god
king i mean obviously our early work is
our best work the stuff we were putting
out in the 60s i think is
it's just under appreciated it's a shame
that the culture's forgotten yeah
jeremy's 87 yeah he looks great right
yeah hey well that's jeremy's razors at
work there you go
the most amazing thing about and i
haven't said this anywhere obviously
this is my first uh
time on the show and my first time to
share this information publicly we've
sold 25 000 razer subscriptions in our
first three days as a company which is
an amazing thing obviously and it makes
the joke much funnier the thing you have
to know about me is that i like to tell
very very expensive jokes smokey mike
and the god king being one of them
and and i like to tell jokes where
people don't know if you're kidding or
not that's always very important to me
and with with this i was so incensed by
not not by harry's razors pulling their
ads which that's just the market at work
if an advertiser wants to pull their ads
out of our shows because they you know
they're going through an economic hard
time if they're going to pull ads from
our show because the ads aren't working
if they just don't like the cut of our
jib all of that is fair game
if they attack us on their way out
publicly well that's just bad behavior
that's rude behavior we were good
partners we told our audience leverage
our personal credibility to tell our
audience about harry's razors our
conservative audience by the way harry's
knew what they were getting they knew
what they were buying and on their way
out they decided to virtue signal
and respond to a tweet that had two
followers and say
that we had inexcusable views and a case
of values misalignment and i thought
well i
i still have the same audience i had
yesterday why don't i tell that audience
that harry's doesn't want their business
i don't see why we should that's why we
should put up with that we'll save
something too because i just want to run
through the intros but we'll loop back
and wait there's intros yeah yeah i
thought the whole thing was like an
extended commercial yes yeah
you still have my introduction time
right we
could you know should we should we pause
and discuss what percentage i'm going to
be getting oh no
by the way old smokey mike and the god
king i you know i don't know what smokey
mike's talents are but i know the god
king never released a hit without him so
there you go
um i'm seamus coughlin of freedom tunes
we just released a video this morning as
well as a video two days ago tim voiced
dr fouching both of them they were both
a blast to make i really recommend you
guys go check those out and if you want
to donate at patreon you'll get to see
the behind the scenes of tim and i
recording it doing some improv and the
whole production coming together so but
it was a lot of fun yeah uh uh it's also
sheamus birthday
[Music]
which is why they forced me to come back
i was like a little little old to be a
virgin
well actually you're not told to be a
virgin if you're not married there you
go i've heard that from age 27 to 30 is
this eternal return and what you do for
those years basically dictates what
you're going to be doing for the rest of
your life
not a one-to-one ratio but it worked
that way for me i will say that the
prohibition against pre-marital sex in
the bible was meant to encourage people
to get married yeah exactly i will not
just masturbate late into old no you
should i mean you just shouldn't
masturbate at all
let's go let's talk about that on the
after show because i don't know
for the after show yeah oh i hate ian
crossland here and you know i don't use
a straight edge i have it in a long time
anyway but if you guys looking at uh
going into electric razors ooh
i like that i like where you're uh all
right where your where your razors are
at
all right anyway i'm just gonna pass
this over to lydia
thank you ian i appreciate that i'm very
excited to be here tonight love jeremy
bourne he's one of my favorite
non-commentators of the daily wire
somebody in the comments was saying that
he is smart and polished so i'm really
looking forward to tonight's show
i'm one of her favorite non-commentators
yeah that's right because you you keep
it i've already heard some comments
precise i was gonna say you're like me
and that you save up your words and keep
it down yeah that's great before we get
started head over to timcast.com become
a member help support our work directly
and you'll get access to exclusive
segments of this show tim casserole
podcast will be up around 11 or so p.m
we do that monday through thursday at 8
p.m so of course we usually have the
spicier show the not family friendly all
the swearing and drinking and fighting
yeah all that uh happens in the members
on the show i'm not kidding about the
fighting we had a guy here you know and
he said it's good times
yep you know those things happen on the
members on the program because we we
like to
i guess have fun whatever uh but support
our work directly at timcast.com you can
also smash the like button right now
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends if you really do
want to help us out and we got to read
this first story
in just three days
the jeremy's razor's twitter account
surpasses harry's inn followers so many
of you heard a little bit already about
this you know a little bit about it for
those that aren't familiar harry's
razors
is woke they denounced the daily wires
audience the daily wire launched their
uh their own version essentially
jeremy's razors which now has a what do
you say jeremy 25 000 subscriptions 25
000 subscriptions in 72 hours i'll just
say real quick and we get to the
beginning the story of all this um
the building of culture yeah the
building of infrastructure which means
the ability for someone to buy a razor
you know people watch netflix because
where else can you go well now the daily
wires got something people buy harry's
razors because or gillette because they
need razors and these companies are
investing your money in things that you
don't value or in people that hate you
so what the daily wire is doing is
profoundly important many people are
doing it but you guys seem to be leading
the charge so jeremy do you want to you
want to tell us just a bit about how
this started yep your position and where
you're at
yeah absolutely i mean what you said i
think is is a big part of it like
conservatives have been you know sort of
in retreat for most of my life certainly
for the last 15 or 20 years and as a
result of that
we've sort of taken a very pessimistic
view conservatives spent a lot of time
lamenting the loss of the past lamenting
uh the loss of the economy lamenting the
loss of their place in the culture and
daily wire has a different attitude
we're we're not lamenting anything we're
happy to be alive right now like i'm
glad that we live at a time where uh
black people people can drink from the
same water fountains that i do i'm glad
whatever a water fountain is i mean i
guess they can drink from the same water
bottles right that i can uh and i'm glad
that uh you know we have penicillin like
there's a lot of that's great about the
modern age um what i want to do is take
the great values that were established
and worked in the past learn from the
past and build on a foundation i want to
be proactive i want to i want to be
optimistic about the future i don't want
to lament the past i want to build the
future and so when someone like harry's
virtue signals publicly and and attacks
my business
i want to build my own business like
conservatives deserve razors too and and
i think that it's an important
you know the left these world
corporations they think that they can
sort of rip
the culture in half and not pay any
economic consequence for it so i want to
rip the economy in half i want to say no
if you can't just
alienate 50 of the audience
of the people in the country and still
expect them to buy your goods and
services they should buy their own goods
and services and that sounds like i'm
saying that i think we should be further
balkanized that i think that we should
be further divided i do in the short
term but i don't in the long term i
desire a country where we're all uh
citizens together where we can where we
can embrace disagreement where we can
embrace political processes i just think
things are so out of alignment right now
that to return to a place like that you
have to create economic incentive and
the only way to create economic
incentive it's not with temporary
boycotts
it's not with complain culture
online it's not with doom scrolling it's
with
actively building things that req that
now require companies like harry's to
compete for our business exactly
competition competition so so uh did
harry's have any wind of what you guys
were planning on doing or do you want to
just give us the quick version of the
story for anyone who doesn't know
absolutely so one of uh the people who
works for me a peon named michael
knowles oh the worst
i know none of you have ever heard of
him who who has
michael was on a podcast with another of
our hosts candice owens but it was not a
daily wire podcast it was a prager
university podcast and it wasn't uh a
year ago it was several years ago wow
and they had a conversation about how
gender dysphoria
has historically been categorized as a
mental illness i believe it is it
currently in the dsm-5 and it was that
was the conversation it was a
respectable conversation a respectful
conversation
fast forward a couple of years one year
ago in march one year ago right now
and a twitter account that had two
followers a high schooler a high
schooler with two followers
uh pointed out to harry's uh that this
conversation had taken place and harry's
immediately reacted
on their twitter account and said you
know this is inexcusable this is values
misalignment we're pulling all of our
ads
and we're gonna and we're gonna make
sure there's no further values
misalignment and how we and how we
conduct our sponsorships well when you
do that
you're signaling to all of my other
advertisers
that the only excusable thing to do
would be to also pull your business from
the daily wire that makes it an attack
on my business right it's not just you
taking your spend which you can do
anytime you want it's you attacking
your company a company that had been
your partner previously it's also
attacking my audience you're saying my
entire audience an audience you paid us
to go help you sell razors too has
inexcusable values uh
and i'm just not gonna put up with that
anymore i think one of the beauties of
this medium that we all have this this
digital presence that we all have is
that there are so many fewer gatekeepers
i don't have to make you know the radio
syndication network happy uh they the
radio syndication network
wants you to just take cancellations
laying down because they have other
shows they don't want to get into a war
with the advertisers but you know with
your show with our shows we're still
going to have the same number of people
watching tomorrow
no whether harry's razors advertises
with us or not so why wouldn't i embrace
that freedom why wouldn't i use that
that that same amount of time that i
used to spend telling people to buy
harry's which by the way harry's is a
great razor i was proud to tell people
to buy harry's as proud that we
supported the work that you know
supported their product
but they don't want my audience to buy
their razors clearly so i'm gonna spend
that same amount of time telling my
audience that harry's don't want their
business and i do and you're gonna make
more money
do you ever think that adding like an
extension to the handle of the razor
would be good so you can shave your back
yeah absolutely well it sounds dangerous
yeah it could be a little bit yeah maybe
put a warning label back shaving that
would do it no but just thinking for the
future just in case a back shaver we all
we all have back shaver problems
at some point like we're gonna have him
today but the day is coming that's right
yeah so so where are you at you're what
did you can you mention how many
subscriptions 25 000 subscriptions we've
sold uh in 72 hours which makes us the
dog who caught the car i mean for us the
commercial was everything and this is
what i told my team all year we were
sourcing razors we were mixing up
shaving creams and seeing if we liked
them what was important to me though was
whether we ever sell a razor or not the
commercial has to be a statement about
the daily wire it has to be a statement
about our brand it has to say that we're
proactive that we're having a good time
that we're looking to the future that
we're not going to take cancellations
laying down um it has to remind our
audience what we are and what we stand
for if we happen to sell any razors
it'll just make the joke that much
funnier well now i'm the dog who caught
the car i have an actual business now i
have to stand up over the next two weeks
to make sure that we can keep up with
the demand that's out there for these
races is it that a year a year ago i
just want to get the timeline actually a
year ago they pulled the ads a year ago
they pulled the app so you've been in in
the process this last year building
everything and how long did it take to
produce the commercial
it was a three-day shoot and and uh five
or six weeks of post-production to get
the commercial out nice five million
views since the 22nd so not even two
full days it's 4.9 million views yeah
it's amazing was that a real
flamethrower
it's a real flamethrower it's not the
smartest idea i ever had to fire a
flamethrower in my office but it's
definitely the most badass and you know
it's easy and it
now
works
the boring company yeah is it made by
the boring company it is the boring
company flamethrower okay yeah
jeremy boring i fired the boring
flamethrower
it was not boring
oh that's awesome do you believe in
synergy like in like divine
inner confluence and things i definitely
believe that if elon musk will retweet
my razor company i will sell even more
bajillions of razor blades yeah
i i'll actually this will be the most
kiss assy thing that i say on the show
elon musk is the greatest living
american he's the most important person
in the country because he has an
affirmative vision for the future of the
country i don't i don't know his
politics i'm sure i disagree with him on
50 of everything but that's a guy who
has a vision for what we can be tomorrow
he's not he's not one of these like
boomer lefties who's still fighting the
cultural revolution of the 1960s or the
economic revolution of the 1920s in
europe you know trying to socialize
country and he's not a boomer
conservative who's just talking about
how great things used to be back when we
were uh still young and rock and roll
he's the guy who's going no no we can
actually build something we can build
our best days are ahead of us let's go
build them we were talking about
leadership last night and savannah
hernandez was saying we need leaders and
i thought yeah you don't but you what
you don't want is a guy to step on be
like i'm your leader now you want
someone like elon or like you that's
like building something that people can
you're just casually building it and
people look at you like a leader because
of what you've created and what you're
creating i agree with you that i'm a lot
like elon yeah
your beard's very nice by the way i
don't know if i mentioned that earlier
and i think for for the average person
you know they would they just look at
elon and you as very very wealthy
successful people who have a vision for
something elon though is you know one of
the is he the richest guy the richest
guy on the planet i think that's a good
story i think bezos has ahead of him no
i think it doesn't even if bezos is
ahead today you just have to remember
that spacex hasn't gone public oh wow
all of elon's wealth really is tesla
right i mean when we think of his vast
wealth as tesla what happens when you
take spacex public i mean the
the amount of money that that guy is
actually worth i think is
dude he called it starlink i think he's
actually going to be linking star
systems with that yeah i don't know
maybe one day he'll build a dyson sphere
but i think we're a long way a long ways
away from that
well time time can condense you know
when you have a lot of time and space
are the same thing so if you can move
fast enough you can and if a lot of
people are working together it kind of
condenses time too and if you have
drones building things all at once in
space you can compile like large
spacecraft really quickly
self-replicating machines we send off to
other planets perhaps to just
carry on the american vision perfect
that's it that's the end of existence i
think you make an interesting point it's
true that unfortunately a lot of what
conservatives has been conservatives
have been doing for the past 10 or 20
years has more or less just been
complaining about the left and it's
really important for us to forward our
own vision that's a huge part of what i
try to do agree or disagree with me
that's part of why i'm frequently
talking about my faith and my own
particular vision for conservatism
because even though i enjoy making fun
of the left and pulling them apart we
actually have to give people something
that they can believe in instead of just
saying that's bad don't do it well let's
let's talk about that so uh you guys are
making movies we are daily wire uh
you're making shows too
what's how does it come to be that the
daily wire you guys you guys are our
news aggregators and commentators for
the most part now you're in this
cultural space
how does that happen it was always part
of the vision right we
the company was founded in la obviously
ben's lived in la every minute that he
wasn't at harvard uh i spent 20 plus
years in la before moving the company to
nashville at the end of 2020 andrew
clavin screenwriter novelist was with
the company from the very beginning
there's always been this really
kind of hollywood
foundation to what we do you know i made
a bunch of movies in in a previous life
that
they all failed but i made them i'm
proud of them um and so when when ben
and i made the decision that we wanted
to get into business together one of the
things that that i told him and it was
an idea that
another conservative commentator bill
whittle
helped me formulate was that if we built
a media company that was large enough we
would actually have a spotlight and we
could shine that spotlight
on
other kinds of projects that we might
want to make what happened and so for me
that was always movies like i had a
production company with with some young
actors
when i was in my early and mid-20s i had
a production company later in life
called declaration entertainment that
was sort of
just
just probably ahead of its time and
underfunded to actually be what it maybe
could have been
but was sort of intended to be like a
crowd crowdfunding uh film company
before there were crowdfunding companies
the
so that was always part of what i wanted
but i thought what we would do is we
would build up a big enough audience
that if i went and made something on the
side i could promote it to me that's how
i saw it but what happened to in 2020
you know
everybody went home because of covid our
office is on ventura boulevard in la
it's the second time we've had to board
up because black lives rally is is uh
black lives matter is rallying on the
street and we're afraid they'll burn
down our building and i'm so i'm on this
the third floor of this office building
with my business partner it's completely
empty because no one's been to work in
weeks and weeks and weeks
and i said hollywood's over
like what can they make now they've
they've decided that the police are bad
literally 40 of everything that
hollywood makes is about a cop
they can't do anything if this is the
position they're going to take and
that's when we realized not only had we
built that spotlight that ben and i had
always wanted to build
but we had built something else too we
had actually built
the distribution mechanism because we
had built this streaming video on demand
platform for our podcast for the video
versions of our podcasts and it just
occurred to us in that moment you know
the technology is agnostic as to what
the content is we've essentially built
netflix we just haven't put movies on it
yet so if we if we
bring in the one other thing you need
for for a successful entertainment
company is just production if we bring
in production we actually have marketing
and distribution why don't we give that
a try and as
because you know i know there isn't a
god but if you ever think about how
if you ever think about how the world
has so much purpose and how everything's
so complex and beautiful it's almost
like a god-like being probably from
outer space built at all not god because
that would be a silly thing like a crazy
person but like just a god-like being
you know if you really think about it uh
that when the god-like being sometimes
there's this like
fortuitousness or providence that
happens in the world and as we're having
this thought dallas sonja who's been a
guest on this show
called me and said hey
i made this great movie called run hide
fight
and hollywood won't buy it because i've
basically been blacklisted and we just
saw that as an opportunity to test the
theory if we put a great production
through our marketing and through our
distribution mechanism what will happen
it was an unbelievable success for us
the movie paid for itself in something
like
seven days and we realized
we realized that we had an actual now
opportunity and and i always think
opportunities are always
responsibilities so now i say we have a
responsibility to go chase this let me
tell you about impact i would i would
like uh for you sir to please read the
headline on the screen
i
i watched a bin shapiro movie by
accident that's right yeah this is some
leftist who watched uh i believe they
watched shut in
and liked it so much they tweeted how
much they liked it saying if you're
looking for something to watch shut in
is pretty fun and vincent gallo gets his
ass kicked if you're that sort of thing
that's a tweet i wrote a couple weeks
ago late on saturday night it no longer
exists the reason doesn't exist is
because almost immediately after i
posted it i got a dm from a friend uh
you know that movie was produced by the
ultra right-wing daily wire with only
ultra right-wing producers talent and so
forth for the market um what no no
delete delete what yep they're trying to
make real movies now sneak that ish in
under the cover of actual production
values for f's sake this always happens
to me i will be watching an ultra
evangelical movie and that realizes
ultra evangelical i'll be listening to
christian radio and i realize it's a
christian radio if jesus is around i
need him to announce himself or i'll
just think he's from brooklyn
the funny part the funny thing about
this is that
i hope it's satire and it may be but um
i'm assuming it's not i don't know it's
the great it's the greatest article i
mean at the end
they say maybe if you keep doing this
maybe one day i'll watch one of your
movies on purpose
but but but here's
real quick we did talk about the other
day but i just want to point out uh you
know with you here at your thoughts this
is someone who's saying they actually
really enjoy
evangelical movies or the daily wires
content but
it says a lot that they're unwilling to
watch things they enjoy
because of of cult-like behavior and so
the point i made before we got on the
show is
thinking about your commercial with
jeremy's razors it's it's an objectively
funny commercial
okay obviously you know humor is
addictive to a lot of people but it's
it's very much in line with a lot of the
you know the real american heroes bits
that were happening out through the
2000s 2010s you know real men of
whatever and that stuff and it's an
over-the-top it's silly use a
flamethrower to torch and there's a lot
of jokes it's funny the the native
american elizabeth warren you have
standing behind you a lot of jokes in
there the people who claim it's not
funny they don't like it they're only
saying that because they're part of a
cult they have to adhere to that's right
privately they admit they like your
movies but they must say they don't like
it for the sake of their political tribe
well also when these people say
something isn't funny am i supposed to
sit there and go well you know the
things you think are hilarious tend to
be really valuable and enjoyable to
watch so of course i trust your opinion
on this
none of their comedy is good but part of
why i think this and i could be wrong
part of why i think that this is
probably satire is because unfortunately
most of the stuff that conservatives and
evangelicals make tends not to be funny
or entertaining and they're saying that
they keep seeing things made by
evangelicals that they don't know are
evangelical which is kind of part of why
i'm thinking it's satirical but it could
be wrong i'd like to quote um
justin roiland or his character rick
sanchez
your booze mean nothing i've seen what
makes you cheers yeah that's the truth
so there you go i mean first of all the
funny thing is
they cheered for you got your guys movie
and they're only doing it now when they
realized who made it i'm like nah you
can't take it back you cheer for it we
know you like it yeah that's right yeah
yeah as an insecure artist uh
you know anytime anybody says they like
anything that i did i don't hear
anything they say after that it's
no bad
so what's the plan what's what's next tv
shows tv shows movies we you know as
with the razer company we just see a lot
of opportunity in
in the destruction that the left is is
bringing to the culture right now i mean
i think it's tragic listen if i could
snap my fingers and put the country back
together and have everything be like it
was back when i grew up i'd probably do
it if i could be dictator that's what
i'd i'd just say hey it should be 1990s
all over again i kind of liked the night
the 90s
yeah like there was no the races all got
along and everybody was doing pretty
well 401k was not bad that's right
transformers beast wars come on dude 97.
but you can't do that and it would be
disingenuous for us to say
in all of this uh destruction there's
not an opportunity for creativity no
absolutely there is and we should take
it but
i will i totally agree and this is part
of why i got into this fear firstly i
just always wanted to make entertaining
content i i lean right people on the
show who watch me regularly know this
and what ended up happening is i just
got to a place after i launched my
channel and was doing these political
cartoons for a little while where i just
realized i didn't really need to try to
put a message into anything i just
needed to make something that i thought
was funny and my values would naturally
come out in it so often what happens
when conservatives try to make content
or evangelicals christians even
catholics try to make content is they
will really hit you over the head with
what the central message is supposed to
be instead of just making something
that's enjoyable to watch and it turns
out really cheesy now what's ended up
happening over the past couple years is
the left has adopted that strategy and
so much of what they produce is message
first substance later and so you're
absolutely correct that they're tearing
their whole empire down because i
remember as a kid we used to watch films
and television shows from the 1950s or
60s with our dad and he would make
comments about how they could never make
that today now we're saying that about
things that were made 10 years ago yeah
that's right
um how do you guys get around the esg
stuff that's been coming
you're familiar with the what what is it
in environmental social governance yeah
yeah so for real real quick for those
that aren't familiar this is basically
social credit scores for businesses
and they expect you to be woke to have
these you know diversity statements
otherwise they could negatively impact
everybody get loans and things like that
so the daily wire is making all this
content you guys are are going after
culture but isn't there a risk there if
these other institutions come at you
yeah i mean there's a lot of risk
everywhere one of the problems i think
that conservatives face right now in in
the economy more broadly is there are so
many potential vectors of attack
uh and you could put a lot of money into
chasing any one of them and then that
could just not be where the attack comes
so you wasted all of your resources
trying to plan for a disaster that never
came and now the disaster can come from
a whole other angle an example of this
conservatives want to build their own
social media platforms right now you
know you hear every time i talk to any
sort of like conservative billionaire
the first thing they say is when are we
going to get a facebook and i say uh
facebook is 20 years old bud uh you will
probably get one ten years from now it's
been half a biblical generation since it
was created so i think that you're
you're getting close soon you will have
one but that's the whole problem with
conservatism uh from an investment class
point of view most concern high net
worth conservatives made their money in
energy or they made their money in real
estate they made their money in
agriculture very conservative ways of
making money
uh the result of that is if a kid with a
backpack walks into their family office
and says hey i designed an app that lets
you rank how hot girls on campus are i
think if you gave me a little capital i
could turn it into the dominant
communication platform uh ever conceived
in all of human history they would call
security and throw that guy out now 20
years later they go why don't we have a
seat at that table but if the if a kid
with a backpack walked in now and
pitched them blockchain or pitched a
meta they would have the same reaction
that they had 20 years so it's like i
bet we have a conservative facebook in
10 years and i bet that we have a
conservative metaverse in 45 years from
now right like that's that's the problem
and so
but as with all problems it creates
certain opportunity we found an early
investor in our company who was able to
get us off the ground we took money from
them that helped us for the first 14
months in month 14 the daily wire was
cash flow positive we've paid for all of
our growth
since then out of cash flow we did 120
million dollars of revenue in the last
12 months uh you know it's a it's a
sometimes i get angry when people are
like uh billionaires pay for everything
you do no no no
like many companies we we were
privileged to get some startup capital
but we funded all of this out of our
success so you you're just saying uh
daily wire pulls in 10 million a month
yep and because and because of that the
esg stuff right now doesn't apply to us
right we don't because we funded our own
growth it's sort of like your situation
here
you've built something now you didn't
even have the amount of startup capital
that we had but you've built something
that you own and because you own it you
can't be cancelled from it you can't be
thrown out of it now
our goal at the daily wire is to become
an institution our goal at the daily
wire is to challenge the left uh on an
institutional level because we think
that's the only place that true victory
can take place maybe at some point we'll
have to go to the public markets um
but what we won't do is get caught up in
the csgs if like
it may come to a certain point we have
to decide
do we subject ourselves to forces that
change what we are or do we
not grow and what
the risk i see is uh yeah
well i'll i'll phrase it this way when i
watch that commercial you put out
when i saw the building you were in and
the tv and the structure i'm like that
reminds me of ice you know when i when i
worked there when they were edgy when
they were offensive when they were
shocking the way they designed their
buildings and i was like man is the
daily wire like
vice now like how they used to be
how did vice go from being sex drugs and
rock and roll into wokeness outright you
know establishment
and there comes a time hundreds of
millions in institutional capital they
go public but it's uh they well they
want to i think they're trying to go
through a spack they've wanted to for a
while my understanding is what i was
told by
former higher-ups who were at the
company is that
they had been attacked so many times by
uh their harassment complaints sexual
harassment
that the press was bad
and they had paid people out and there
was a risk of certain stories going
public
so their investors said just declare
yourselves like a feminist company like
make feminist content adopt this
and you'll shield yourself from these
claims and so the id this is what i was
told that um and this is someone who was
like i worked with there i worked at
vice they said when the investors came
in and said be a feminist company and
you will be safer from these attacks
they said okay because the executives
didn't care so my understanding was are
is they were just like hey whatever gets
people off our back you guys no problem
we just want to make cash and run a
business none of these executives care
disney doesn't care about the grooming
law down in florida right of course they
don't they what they care about is their
23 year old woke employees um making it
impossible for them to conduct their
business what they care about is the
fact that the left is so is so skilled
at weaponizing and they want to avoid
those attacks to their business and so
it's a it's a the thing about virtue is
that it's actually a really cheap
currency
you just say something hollywood's
always peddled in this you know even in
the glory days of the 90s you know and
we were all walking around second on a
big gulp or whatever uh you know
everybody in hollywood wanted to save
the freaking whales because of course
they want to save the whales because
when you're on like your third marriage
and yep four out of your five kids are
in rehab and uh you gotta save something
i guess yeah you want everyone needs to
see themselves as good on some level and
if you're good for christians do this
too by the way it
everyone an easy out is to find an
abstract way to be good you know it says
in one of the epistles written by the
apostle john that
it's easier to love your neighbor whom
you know than to love god
and christian every time you talk to a
christian i go well that's not really
true i mean my neighbor's kind of a jerk
my brother's kind of a jerk but of
course i love god and i said well you
don't i mean
god himself in the epistle says that you
don't you say that you do because you've
abstracted a god that you can love
more than your brother whom you know
you've created a god to love who
approves of you and who doesn't have
anything that you disapprove of your
neighbor your brother who you know has
all kinds of crap that you don't approve
of and so you see like it's very easy to
give money to african missionary work or
african charities or to save the whales
or to save the environment these are
ways of abstracting your way out of
having to deal with the messy reality of
the world if you really care about
people
you interact with those actual people
and try to make their
make improvements into their lives right
yeah i would actually agree with that
and i would go as far as to say when
somebody says that they love god but
they hate the people around them don't
do anything to improve their
circumstances either material or
spiritually that person really worships
themselves because their vision of god
is just
as you said something abstract that
caters to all of their particular
desires one thing that i think our
society has really lost is people are
not focused as much on what is near to
them they want to solve problems on the
other side of the world that's a huge
part of progressive politics in fact you
could argue it's the only part of
progressive politics is to defer
responsibility elsewhere historically
people understood you were supposed to
love those closest to you care for your
family first and foremost and then you
started to worry about the people around
you now it's the exact opposite i can
treat my family horribly but as long as
i am theoretically good to someone on
the other side of the world i'm a good
person even though my entire social life
is a complete failure the uh greatest
psychologist of our time has a stage
jordan peterson you have to clean your
room man but that's that's exactly the
meme the meme
you can't change the world if you can't
even get your own life in order yeah but
i want to point something else out too
um well also when i'm when i'm looking
at this article from defector and
they're holding up a sign saying f you
ben ish pirro like just cussing at him i
think to myself
i don't i don't recall seeing
conservatives holding up signs
saying f you jenk yuger or
to be fair obviously sometimes they do
but it's kind of a common occurrence
among the left to hate
and to hate without trying to understand
yeah so i'm thinking about daryl davis
he's been working with bill ottman over
at mines they want to de-radicalize
extremists not de-platform them it's one
of the things they're working on and
daryl davis you know he's the guy who
went to clan meetings a black man and
just talked to these people trying to
understand them ends up de-radicalizing
them it's fascinating because
when i see
how the the modern left the activists
left not like regular run-of-the-mill
you know democrat voters they're you
know mostly just regular people are
paying attention maybe but these
activists just they hate they hate so
much it's the weirdest thing that glenn
beck can tell dave rubin i disagree with
you and i think what you're doing is
wrong but i love you and what do they
say they say f you ben ish piro
i'm like man glenn beck tells the people
he disagrees with that he loves them
they tell you they hate you i don't
understand why anybody would want to be
a part of that yeah well this is the
problem
with
dogma and ideology and politics is that
they allow you not to have to actually
engage with the world as it is
you're only required to engage with the
world sort of as you perceive it
juxtaposed against a code of your
essentially of your own making and
people can say well no my dogma is 2 000
years old or my dogma is
well as you know comes straight from
athens or whatever it is but the truth
is uh
if you're a person who can't engage in
reality
then your dogma is an abstract your
dogma is just a reflection of things
that you want and it's a way of to your
point mitigating responsibility for the
actual people around you you know you
i've thought a little bit about our
i actually was about to say something
that i had committed not to say on the
air so i'm not going to say it nice work
thank you it's it's rare that i make a
good decision but i just made a good
decision i hear you but it's so it's so
important you know god if you're going
to believe in god or the god-like alien
who actually made the heavens and the
earth
there's a whole conversation there
you actually have to believe like god
has to be the god of reality i i took a
friend ten years ago i i'm married uh to
a woman i never talk i know i won't say
her name or talk about her too much but
i will tell you this funny story that uh
i i took a friend's future in-laws out
to a movie ten years ago and the first
thing that that his future mother-in-law
said to me after the movie was i said oh
did you enjoy the movie and she goes
well i don't really like movies it's oh
great uh and she said uh uh you know
you you and your wife are mary so yeah
we've been married a short amount of
time she said well you know in god's
eyes she's still married to her first
husband
and and i said oh well god must be an
idiot wrong because that's not true but
that's not that is not reality god has
to be the god of reality not the god of
an abstract fantasy but i think i so i
would argue as a christian that's an
abstract fantasy that you can divorce
and remarry if it was a legitimate
marriage in the first place because one
of the definitions of marriage is that
it's a lifelong commitment until death
do you part
but what would you argue as a sheamus
as a shameless i mean that's my belief
do you like do you actually believe it
or do you just believe that the
christians believe it no i believe it i
mean i believe i i think most christians
don't believe it unfortunately i i think
a lot of christians have abandoned that
it's not a popular teaching anymore i
suppose you could define the word
marriage meaning to mix so if you're
going to mix your soul with something if
there is a god if there's an energy
field there's no one mixing that soul
that's a good point well no there's no
there's no one unsaluting a solution but
i think you can reverse a mixture if you
mix red and blue paint together you
ain't getting them back out
right yeah i mean that that that i don't
know it's a meaningless analogy so i
understand it though yeah but let's
let's let's
i'll push back on that just a little bit
sure god's the god of reality divorce
exists in the bible uh that's not a
recommendation of divorce which is a
horrible terrible thing
um but the the idea that god lives in a
sort of abstract where things are as
they should be
how far back do you
how far back do you take that
essentially if that's the case then god
still lives in eden
before the fall happened god still lives
in a place where people haven't been
living in sin where people haven't been
making mistakes where none of the sort
of causal you know none of the
eventualities that came from that
causality of sin have ever occurred and
god is abstracted out of being the god
of actual people in an actual place in
an actual time uh the god of the the god
of the bible in my estimation is a god
who actually took on sin and took on the
consequences of sin on himself in christ
as a result of that he becomes god of us
of a reality that's
he becomes god of the people who have
existed in reality not just the people
who could have existed in the abstract
so i just think that any time that we
used see this is a great example that's
a place where we use sort of a dogma or
an ideology to deny a reality that's
right in front of us i think you see it
a lot with what's happening in in
ukraine right now by the way where
regardless of your opinion about nato
expansion regardless of your opinion
about uh the merits of zelinski
regardless of your opinion about a lot
of things like vladimir putin actually
did invade ukraine and ukraine did not
want to be invaded and you see a lot of
people left in right but particularly on
the right who are almost in denial
about that situation because it doesn't
line up with their political point of
view they have a political point of view
uh that um that ukraine shouldn't have
done certain things
or or or that putin was more friendly to
the west than he actually turned out to
be or that friend or that putin was a
better representative even you even hear
people on the right right now saying
that putin was a better representative
of christianity because he built a
cathedral you know at one point in time
or something and then actual reality
takes place in front of them they have a
very hard time pivoting to accept it
because it's because it's out of line
with their expectations based on how
they thought the world should be
yeah
man of the year
and they did appease him for a long time
so i i hear some what you're saying and
i i agree with some of what you're
saying but i would say where we
definitely disagree is that i would
argue that god
having moral prescriptions for us that
we ourselves do not live up to does not
mean that he's over abstracted or
doesn't govern our reality because it's
actually christ in scripture who who
says
what uh god has has brought together let
no man put asunder and anyone who leaves
their husband commits adultery etc the
challenge he also says if you have lust
in your heart you are an adulterer yeah
you're not an adult you're not on the
path to adultery you're not kind of like
an adulterer if you really think about
it yeah you are wise
if you're in a marriage and you're
thinking about having sex with another
woman does that make you cheating on
your wife yes that's adultery of the
heart that's crazy how do you control
your thought like you got to learn to
control your thoughts yeah absolutely
custody of thoughts i mean nothing
happens in the world that didn't first
happen in the human heart well let's
let's i would actually disagree i think
the entire purpose of the sermon on the
mount is to get us out of these
abstractions it's to con it's to bring
the full weight of condemnation to it's
so that no one can claim not to be an
adulterer not so that we can also try to
figure out how to not commit adultery in
our heads i so i would absolutely agree
that people should not be sitting here
and it is certainly not not my claim to
say that i am not a sinner
or that i have not committed adultery of
the heart etc it's simply to say that i
don't believe recognizing that negates
the moral precepts that christ put
forward these are
very profound moral ethical and
religious questions that are very
difficult to uh to get into especially
you know we could talk a bit more about
i suppose in the members only segment if
you guys want to get into the core of it
because i love having these
conversations but
when you got into ukraine i was like
let's let's let's segue you know and
then it's like it gets pulled back into
the full size they need razors in
ukraine let's talk about they do so here
basically more than ever this is me
navigating a very hard segue back to
this topic which we had pulled up which
is biden warning of real food shortages
uh food charge risk over russia's
invasion into ukraine
we've been hearing murmurs about this
but it's very obvious ukraine is the
breadbasket of europe they produce wheat
russia exports fertilizer we're no
longer able to buy that fertilizer for
the most part the prices are
skyrocketing which means the spring
planting season will be limited and that
also means the fall harvest will be
severely stunted so you can expect to
see food shortages here and in europe
and biden is warning about it i think
there's a couple things to point out one
is
that biden has basically said we're
going to what did he say we're going to
disseminate food shortages around the
world yeah what a ridiculous thing to
say sounds like a biden thing to say
yeah but you know people will be like
what he really meant was we're going to
disseminate food around the world well
you don't know what he meant he said
he's going to make food shortages worse
the other thing is this is the direct
result
of a lack of culture coming from the
right because politics is downstream
from culture as andrew breitbart said
and when you get
a 2020 in which every channel every
movie every media outlet is all
screaming orange man bad it lights
people up to get out there and i i
always bring up the story man people i
know who have no business in politics i
certainly think they have a right to be
but these are people who couldn't tell
you what the supreme court was how many
justices it has or even name a single
member of congress going out and voting
why
because their media and their culture
tells them what to do
now we're seeing the ramifications of
this joe biden as president is not
responsible for every crisis we're
dealing with but he's certainly a bad
leader who said he's going to be
disseminating food shortages
now we get to experience those food
shortages
because to stop literal hitler you would
elect anyone yep
it looks like the actual quote is uh we
both talked about how we could increase
and disseminate more rapidly food
shortages
it's a great quote that's our biden
[Music]
no just makes it just makes me
contemplate time you know
yes please the passage that's the
passage
situation five years ago like yeah we're
gonna have these food shortages and the
president's gonna go oh he's gonna
distribute the food shortages
um imagine being donald trump speaking
at a rally and saying if you vote for
joe biden you're going to have your gas
prices are going to go way up the
economy is going to be bad and you get
freaking fact checked and shut down on
facebook for saying it probably at the
time yeah missing context they would
have said oh yeah yeah no for sure i
remember this one fact checker
someone quote tweeted me because i
talked about bill clinton epstein's
plane
and they fact checked it as false when
you click the fact check it's it
explained in great detail how i was
correct yeah they it's it's the most
insane thing
they did it to josh hawley uh politifact
did it where they were like josh hawley
says that you know judge jackson was
lenient to let's just say child abusers
very extreme child abusers and they're
like mostly false and then you scroll
down it's like well it's true she was
lenient to these people it isn't a a a
it isn't out of the ordinary for judges
to be lenient and it's like did he say
it wasn't he just gave a fact so
well this is the reality of where you're
at when your cultural institutions are
dominated by a cult and by people who
are are intent on just controlling the
system even even if it means bringing it
to the ground yeah the institutions in
this country were always the real
bulwark against uh state and corrosion
state intrusion into our lives right you
had the states actually created the
federal government so that they're like
the ultimate pre-federal institution you
had the church which was one of the most
important institutions in the country
you had other institutions though
corporate america i think the
probably the the
it's unpleasant to say like probably the
institution that mattered the most in
many ways uh as a bulwark against state
power you had uh the family the ultimate
institution and
what the left has done over the since
the 60s is they've infiltrated every one
of those institutions
since the state automatically
essentially desires what the left
desires
a state
the natural state of a state is to grow
its power over the individual
which is a which is a left-wing goal
since that is the truth when when the
left takes over all the institutions
that allowed
uh the the people to
essentially it solves the collective
action problem of the people in
defending their rights against the state
once once the institutions are on the
left the institutions immediately
essentially become
an arm of the state and you see that
with all these fact checkers you know i
actually i have a soft spot for for
facebook i mean daily wire has been the
number one publisher in the world on
facebook 15 months in a row wow
we do really well on facebook i think
mark zuckerberg if you were to talk to
him personally
wouldn't see himself as a guy who has
taken voices away from so many people he
would see himself as the guy who's given
a voice to a billion people
nevertheless the institution that he's
created because you know 30 000 people
at facebook all walk in lock step uh
with the left they've become an arm of
the state and so instead of corporate
america now it's all the things we've
been talking about all night hr and all
these things instead of corporate
america solving the collective issue uh
the collective um
action problem of the individual they
actually become a part of the state's
power to set to shut down the individual
that's why you get these incredibly
orwellian expressions like fact checking
how can you have a fact check that says
you are mostly
false that something is mostly false
which is completely true and what the
answer is that missing context or mostly
false the piece that they say was
missing or uh that would have
that created the falsehood is just their
point of view not more information not
more fact their point of view missing
context if i say joe biden isn't a good
president you know they will say uh fact
check mostly false missing context and
you'll read the article and we'll say
well
hyperinflation
uh war overseas the end of american
hegemony gas prices through the roof
food shortage food shortages being
disseminated around the globe but other
presidents have been bad
they would say joe biden actually
promised to disseminate those food
shortages so he's keeping his campaign
promises he's a good president let me
ask you we've had we've had a few people
on the show we recently had uh a more
middle of the road guy on the show and
uh sometimes we hear this from the from
the moderates that you know oh the both
sides things i think both sides have
their problems or whatever my response
to this is like look man i i personally
have never been the staunch conservative
guy i've actually when i was younger i
went to catholic school up until i was
in sixth grade then i went like anarcho
punk rock hang out with these hardcore
like lefties and then eventually kind of
just found a middle of the road place
but
when you have
i love going through the list of stories
covington kids russiagate ukraine gates
jesse smallette uh michael brown trayvon
martin lie lie lie lie lie over and over
again at a certain point why aren't
these people being like i was lied to i
shouldn't listen anymore you know you've
got these fact checkers who come out and
they fact check stories that later turn
out like the hunter biden laptop all the
factions doesn't later turn out to be
always true
they always knew that it was true so how
like what's your view on this look i
talk about i call it a cult all the time
we call this that we call them the city
urban liberal types sorry uh people
living in cities but you're the cult and
uh
what are your thoughts on this why are
they faking it are they lying are they
just stupid i agree that it's a cult uh
to some degree i mean it looks like a
cult if it looks like a cult right and
smells like a cult but i think that
andrew klavan talks about this from time
to time i i'm loathe to agree with
andrew clavin on anything
but on just this one thing he he did
christen me the god king so on these two
things i agree with andrew
everything we're living through right
now
is because we as a species
have not evolved
to under to know what to do with the
internet
you know the the protestant reformation
in many ways was a reaction to the
advent of the printing press that it
seems funny to us so far down the road
from the printing press the printing
press was such a remarkable
leap forward in technology for human
beings suddenly there was information
available to everyone that formerly had
only been available to the very very
elite few
and
to come to grips with that
took two generations and a war that pro
that wiped out millions of people in
europe like
that ripped the church asunder that
ripped the world order asunder
they printed words on paper and the
protestant reformation happened
basically as a result and it's always
that way when you have these moments of
you know in many ways uh world war one
was a reaction to the industrial
revolution when there's these enormous
leaps forward in technology people don't
know what to do with it it takes a
generation or two
the the internet
literally rewires our brains it has it
has biological uh
ramifications we have so much
information more information than any
human being knows what to do with we
have not solved how to take in all that
information how to sort through all of
that information how to come to
conclusions and so what we've done
is we've the same thing we did when the
printing press happened we've just
become more tribal since i can't sort
through all the information i have to
believe that tim knows how to sort
through the information i have to
believe that jordan peterson knows how
to sort through the information i have
to believe that ben shapiro knows how to
sort through the information i have to
believe and the problem with that is
some of the sorters are better than
others
i was wondering uh you know joe biden
recently came out and said he he uh
referenced the fourth turn the fourth
turning the stras how generational
theory are you familiar i imagine he
said you know between 1900 1946 you know
what do you say 60 million people died
yeah then there was a liberal world
order there will be a new world order i
was wondering we talked a bit about how
we brought that up but i thought to
myself why was it that so many people
died between 1900 and 1946 you know what
was the catalyst for these emergent
ideologies that that opposed each other
so so fiercely and i wonder if it was
radio
all of a sudden we got time serialized
radio programs radio news hitler used
mass media exactly how he became hitler
so imagine that we know you are the
average person and there's a handful of
newspapers the newspapers mostly
homogenized to maximize profits so they
may have slightly differing views or
they might be yellow it might be yellow
journalism but for the most part your
information moves slowly so
radicalization is slow along comes radio
which is more rapid it's on you know
frequently and there's multiple channels
with different perspectives now they're
finding new audiences because they have
more opportunity to send out those
measures in real time i wonder if that
played a big role in radicalization
which you know give or take 10 20 30
years results in major clashes in war
yeah as it's actually a good thing most
humans don't have time to just live
reading the internet and reading the
news and sifting through the news
disorder they're they're busy working
for a living they're busy raising their
kids and so they they need people to
help them with this fire hose of
information that now comes our way
and yeah i'm sure radio was very similar
i'm sure i know the printing press was
one thing i'll say to bring it full
circle to my conversation about why
conservatives tend not to build the
future it's because yes perhaps the
second world war was a result of radio
perhaps the explosion in in the isms
fascism socialism communism uh anarchism
maybe it was all a result of radio i
think that's a really compelling
theory that you bring up uh
conservatives did get around to being on
the radio though in 1980 so i just want
to i just want to say after 60 million
people were killed because of radio yeah
a generation later we got some no i i
think it's an interesting point and
conservatives have done a very poor job
keeping up with mass communication with
the artistic fields i mean you look
historically so much of the beautiful
art that we see in the west was
basically commissioned by the catholic
church nowadays i mean what fraction of
media does the catholic church let alone
any group you'd call conservative in
general control it's a very small
proportion and i think part of that
could just be the nature of the way
people who tend to be more quote unquote
progressive are willing to experiment
with new technology you were sort of
discussing the fact that conservative
investors would be less likely to put
money into an app that they can't see a
direct utility in the way a left-wing
person might be capable of i'm not sure
but i also think when we talk about
left-wing people today we're not really
talking about the left-wing of 20 years
ago even though they have similar
ideological routes because i think many
of them today wouldn't invest in these
tools healthy society needs a healthy
needs healthy liberals
the reason conservatives don't
conservatives have never made art ever
the catholic church didn't make any art
it bought art from much more liberal
people like michelangelo that a healthy
society has healthy liberals an
unhealthy society has ascendant leftists
wow that's a that's a big difference i
have to talk about that why don't we
make gargoyles anymore
yeah let's bring it no no no no no we
should make some put them around the
corner i'm totally doing it
in large gargoyles we have we have a lot
of work and expansion we're doing i'm
getting gargoyles because you look at
all of these and i'm half kidding about
gargoyles but you look at modern
construction and it's like glass steel
boxes that's right there's no there's no
art or or inspiration and then i'm
thinking about a lot of a lot of
churches and a lot of older buildings
gargoyles and i'm like that sounds kind
of like oh if somebody was the fan of
the lord of the rings they'd be like i'm
building a house i'm going to put a gun
you got to have tubes out of their mouth
that shoot fire though oh yeah they're
just like at will you can push them i
don't know if that's legal but we can
certainly have it spray water you just
have it shoot electricity you're more
conservative than i thought because
that's a very practical that's not a
non-artistic practical thing that you
just uh that you just suggested you know
regarding the fire hose of information
you're talking about with the internet i
would love to be able to understand all
the information on the internet without
having to read it or watch it so i'm
thinking of neural link
it's a bit esoteric because it hasn't
come out yet and i wonder if it's like
we invented the fire hose but we don't
have any of the the mechanism to
to control it really or very well very
rudimentary think about how crazy it's
going to be when person has its own
problems so they actually refer to all
the tweets on twitter as the firehose
you know so if you want to access the
api for certain information or whatever
and some companies do it just like
there's so much information on twitter
i gotta tell you they i i would be
willing to bet the the twitter firehouse
has been plugged into an ai a long time
ago and it's like
a calcul it knows everything happening
it's an oracle at this point i should
also specify i don't know if i want to
see everything on the internet because
the mind can get warped by crazy
violence real quick um you through
twitter's information with everyone
posting things
just think about what happens in new
york city when a uh let's say a
transformer explodes instantly you're
going to have 3 000 tweets all saying
i heard this explosion instantly those
with access to the geolocation data are
going to know exactly where all of those
people are instantly the ai is going to
be able to get this circle on a map of
all these people saying they heard an
explosion and then be able to
triangulate where the explosion was
basically based on how many people are
tweeting about it they'll know exactly
where that is
instantly
think about anything in that regard that
people might talk about be it a storm be
it a flood
there's going to be ai that has access
to
to this fire host now what happens when
you plug into the metaverse and they can
download that rapid information people
will become like
i don't know man what people will become
but you'll just know everything all at
once and that's that's
it's going to be an experience i'll tell
you you need to see this this is funny
because you you made this point earlier
about how
it's good that most people can't just
sit online and consume information all
day and
we have this saying right people joke
about going outside and touching grass
it's like all right bro you're too
online there's this idea of being
terminally on the internet to the point
where you just can no longer recognize
and contend with reality and so if
people do get plugged into that point my
goodness i don't even know what
political ideology they'll have because
some 14 year old will spend hours and
hours and hours online and end up in
more and more bizarre esoteric corners
of the political internet and claim that
that's their view this is happening and
i don't know if you're familiar with
this we've talked about it quite a bit
uh are you familiar with um elsagate no
so this was something that happened uh
about four or five years ago where
youtube was inundated with people
dressing up like elsa from frozen
spiderman oh yeah joker and then uh so
it was these weird videos with no length
with like no speaking just music and the
joker would chase elsa and spider-man
would save her and it was because
algorithmically those characters
generated a lot of hits and
recommendations
so people made content for children but
this began to devolve eventually the
people who made the content many of
these people realized
it's babies watching this stuff babies
can't change the channel it's the auto
play feeding the content so they used
computer programs to procedurally
generate content with these keywords you
ended up with videos that were very
bizarre like uh there's one video one of
the most notable in this space was
a adolf hitler
but his body is a woman in a bikini
doing tai chi as
some indian family sings finger family
nursery rhyme
and the incredible hulk is also like you
know doing like some kind of boxing
maneuver the reason was it didn't matter
what the content of the video was it
would ma it mattered all that matter was
the key words were in it nursery rhyme
finger family the hulk for some reason
hitler i guess these things were
shocking and generated recommendations
children grew up watching this stuff so
when when ian said i'm sorry when
sheamus is talking about their warped
perspective
we are going to have
12 we probably have it now 10 year olds
who are unsupervised on the internet
watching the craziest stuff you will
never understand abstract nonsense of
you know the incredible hulk and hitler
dancing together
and when those people grow up they're
going to have insane views that make no
sense because
when we grew up we're older right i
think james is the youngest person yeah
maybe i don't know is yeah he's youngest
person here 2017. so happy birthday my
parents had were living in reality all
of our parents were living in reality
even with james being the youngest
person but what about one of these kids
who's 10 years old today when they have
their first kid and the values they
transfer down to those children are
telling the great story of hitler's uh
female female hitler's tai chi against
the hulk as their as their story or
whatever like these these things are
going to be pro wired into their brain
when i was a little kid with things that
were wired into my brain were superman
you know batman star trek the next
generation those values carry forward if
little kids are being are developing
around psychotic algorithmic nonsense
yup they're just going to be insane i
just typed in elsagate too to get a look
and i mean there's some crazy girl
drinking a beer like a baby drinking a
beer with a spiderman yo there's elsa
gate had had cartoons on youtube of
little kids drinking urine this is like
r-rated contest
i actually know someone who told me that
their child came across content on the
internet that was supposed to be peppa
pig
and it was actually peppa pig describing
some extremely violent things and
actually basically telling the kids to
do violent things very disturbing very
disturbing yeah i think one of the
things that's missing in our culture now
is cultural literacy
and it's not a topic that gets discussed
much it probably should be discussed a
lot more that when we were kids
uh the the western canon that would
which a canon is important because it's
essentially the set of stories and ideas
that we all share
the western canon was baked into all of
the fiction that we ingested so i
learned the famous story of
of tom sawyer convincing his friends to
whitewash the fence right that's right i
learned that from looney tunes i didn't
learn it from reading huck finn you
couldn't you know
a seven-year-old can't read huck finn
but a seven-year-old could watch looney
tunes i learned about classical music
from looney tunes you know
i i think that that
that idea that we have a shared heritage
that we have a shared fiction even a
fictional a legendary uh heritage you
know the stories that we all know
uh is completely gone and to your point
i i think we are already seeing the
results of it there's never been a
generation with more psychosis oh yeah
than young people today right i mean i
think it's going to get substantially
it's going to get some people don't
worry people don't understand we've been
uh i've been kind of obsessed with
talking about the metaverse just because
i've been you know it's this
i i read news i read politics i read
culture and all of these cultural
stories that keep popping up just lead
me to the singularity you know that's
what i think people call it alex jones
calls it that the metaverse is a path
towards this you know unification of
mana machine or whatever ray kurzweil
thing yeah so the one one of the things
i mentioned was that a lot of what we're
experiencing in in in the culture war
with the transgender issue is actually
um due to technological advancement now
i'm not making a social commentary on
this i'm making a scientific one
when we isolated hormones
and then in the 1960s started creating
hormone therapies this led to a sort of
understanding of what hormones can do to
the body which leads us to the 90s where
hormone replacement therapy becomes more
popular which results to in the 90s you
now have prominent adults who have
underwent or undergone hormone
replacement therapy now sharing those
ideas and expanding that idea
again not a social commentary scientific
one if the debate we're having now
because of the existence in the
isolation and creation of hormones and
that technology has resulted in this
cultural war debate what will happen
when we start shifting into
metaverse spaces
when we're plugging our brains in or
virtual reality to go to work already on
twitter many people use cartoon avatars
or animals as their as their profile
picture
what happens if we really do and i think
we will get to that point where we have
our business meetings in a high-res
metaverse and someone shows up to work
and it's tony the tiger or some giant
ostrich
and they and they say you can't
discriminate on me
on how i choose to represent myself in
the metaverse environment
so right now
if you look at new york city's human
rights law pertaining to gender identity
it's specifically defined as
self-expression no joke literally it's
defined as self-expression and uh i i
this is something i i actually you're
literally not expressing yourself
it's true well i mean yeah you're no
it's true well so so uh uh i covered the
story and i and i actually called the
city and i called some lawyers to to get
some understanding on this this was back
and i think 2018 it was a new york
announced that had 31 genders in their
in their public listing
so
their human rights law specifically says
if you are in any of these categories of
gender or gender identity you are a
protected class if anyone discriminates
against you it's a 125 dollar fine if
they will fully discriminate it's a 200
250 000 fine so i looked into the law
and it said gender identity is defined
as self-expression they can't
discriminate against you based on your
name or the way you dress
so i called several human rights lawyers
and i asked them for an understanding of
this and i said
how how can a workplace determine what
is reasonable or not in terms of
someone's name and expression and
clothing and they said well we all know
what's reasonable a judge knows what's
reasonable that's why judges exist if
you go into their courtroom with
something unreasonable they'll tell you
you're unreasonable and it doesn't it
doesn't fit the law and i said okay
what if someone went to starbucks and
they told the person you know i want to
work here
they get hired but on their first day
they show up in a full wolf costume
with with like lifts so they're six foot
five and they say that their name is
volciferon herald of the winter mists
you can't discriminate on the basis of
my name or my clothing the lawyer i was
told this by several lawyers they all
said
good luck going into a courtroom and
telling a judge that you are vulciferon
and they need to allow you to wear a
wolf costume in starbucks and i said
would not the same thing apply to a man
wearing women's clothing whose legal
name is john saying his name is jane
why would the judge have the discretion
to determine whether or not it falls
within the the legal definition of
self-expression because if you're
telling me that someone can't choose to
be a furry
and furries exist
and they and you know i don't think
they're all calling themselves full
cipher on but they have you know
specific names and costumes
why would a a transgender person be
afforded rights that another person in a
similar fashion would not be and they
had no answer for me other than we think
a judge would find it unreasonable and
then i said wouldn't it stand a reason
then you could appeal and say any judge
could find a transgender person
unreasonable and that would create very
serious problems based on this this
human rights law
that's where i think we're headed now
once we get into the metaverse you're
going to see that very same thing happen
you're going to be you're going to be
around people who say i am a carrot this
is my identity identify as carrot and
you won't be able to fire them or or
admonish them you'll have to just say um
you know robo is a carrot he works here
you might be able to make it so no one
else can see the carrot when they're in
the boardroom but they only see the bass
avatar or something i don't i don't i
don't know about that um
that would that would be like saying if
a protected class of any of any type
gender race national origin came to a
workplace you could cover them up so
none of the employees none of the
customers could see that you could say
like you can express yourself however
you want but you can't make me see you
that's up to me whether or not i see you
tough questions man because they're
saying in workplaces you have to use
pronouns
well and it's interesting because one of
the points you made was that somebody
said well good luck getting in front of
a judge and having them take that
argument seriously i don't think you
need luck it's possible you just need a
couple of years because our our social
structures are shifting so quickly that
even going to court as a transgender
person right and saying i am a
a woman trapped in a man's body you're
discriminating against me if you don't
acknowledge that i mean 20 30 years ago
a judge would have said that's
absolutely absurd but today they
wouldn't right this is actually why
things are moving so quickly that even
we can't
carry on a real conversation about real
about what's actually occurring
when when any of us sit at a table and
we talk about the trans issue we still
use terms like men and women we still
think fundamentally if a man says that
he's a woman if a man named john walks
into starbucks and says i'm a woman and
we think that that's what the trans
conversation is really about but when
you read statistics like 40 of kids now
are trans or whatever these crazy
statistics are they're not having
conversations about being men
men trapped in women's bodies they're
having conversations that are so far
beyond that it's not it's not always the
furry conversation but to your point
there are 33 there are 72 there are 40
this is the number of genders it's sort
of like when when conservative parents
say oh i can put my kid in college you
know it was liberal when i was there and
i came out just fine and you're like you
have no idea what's actually happening
on a college campus right now this is
exactly my point that um
because of the 90s and the technological
advancement around hrt
30 years later we're having a
conversation around transgender issues
but kids today they're talking about you
know other kin are you familiar with
other kids people who think they're
mythical beasts or mythical animals and
when it comes to the metaverse this
won't be a question it will be they will
be and
give it 50 years if we're neural linked
into alternate realities and digital
realities
a lot of the work the work we're doing
right now could be held in a metaverse
space with high quality microphones and
ultra high re you know ultra you know
10k 12k video
we could we don't have to be sitting in
the same room or fly people out we could
all put on our headsets and then people
will watch a video of us in a room
together isn't that crazy they'll sit in
the room yeah exactly i was going to say
someone replace themselves
and you know what's funny is 10 years
ago i pitched this to vice i pitched it
to fusion i said we do a show where in
one chair it's a 360 um um what's the
what's the word binocular um
what's the word i just call it
stereoscopic oh cool stereoscopic 360
view which allows you to see
like you're actually there but the
resolution was really bad but we could
still try it that's coming now if you
get to the point where you can actually
have full sensory feedback like
neurolink would would potentially allow
you to do if we can actually wire a
brain people are literally going to be
like in this space i am vosif around the
wolf lord of you know the the arboreal
forest and you'll be watching a show of
a giant wolf creature and it will look
like reality and the wolf will be like i
take issue with the president's
anti-wolf policies
and people are going to be like wow it
must be crazy being a wolf yeah and then
that person will become a ceo
and the boomers will still be
presidents in real life they'll still
run the whole thing uh i i think what
you're saying is right but i do want to
challenge this a little bit
it is the nature of
uh
it is the nature of contrarians
to and the nature of conservatives uh
not that i want to label you all as that
contrarians though
to look at the future and only see the
worst things that can happen and the
worst things that can happen will happen
well hold on i'm not suggesting that
those things won't occur you're right
they will occur see so this is a point i
was making with with a few other people
me describing the potential future
through the metaverse is not a moral
statement good or bad about it it's just
something i see as a potential
but you do see it as something bad yeah
and i think that the potential that
you're outlining some version of it will
come to pass it's it's not that
it's not that when we look ahead and say
oh you know we're gonna have to be in
business meetings with with volciveron
that we're wrong we probably that is one
of the things that will occur uh
everything that people put their hands
to because because people are falling
because people are broken the things
that we create
reflect our brokenness uh
but they don't exclusively reflect our
brokenness and i think that what we have
to do people in this room people who who
think in the directions that people in
this room think we have to we have to be
active parts of the construction of the
future so that it doesn't just represent
our brokenness it can also represent
a lot of the good thing a lot of the
values that we share a lot of the things
that we would like to see
uh uh expanded here's what i want you to
consider too something that um
most people don't realize
if the metaverse reality comes to pass
where you can choose your identity
you jeremy will be sitting at a daily
wire meeting you'll have hired a young
man named you know ricky smith but when
he shows up on the first first day in
the metaverse he looks identical to you
and he says my name is jeremy this is my
identity and if you were tallied against
me because of my identity that's
discrimination on the basis of who i am
in my name and
it's some they want to be you
people don't want to be themselves the
people who look up to you they'll just
say i'm going to be this person the
number of people who wish that they were
me
is
staggeringly so can you imagine being in
the metaverse walking down the street
and then there's like 10 of you
and then they look at you and they're
like you're not the real jeremy are you
and you're like no no not me and they're
like okay well then the question is do
you yeah do you have the ip of your own
likeness because you will have to buy a
non-fund you'll have to buy a
non-fungible token of yourself you will
like have to pay someone else for it
someone buys this company very
interesting because uh modern like media
law when like disney has a contract with
the guy playing thor whoever that what's
that guy's name chris his name is chris
they have him on contract saying they
own his likeness in perpetuity forever
and every universe henceforth which
means if they ever want to make a
a deep fake with chris hemsworth saying
whatever they want they own that yo this
was chris hemsworth's likeness now this
was a plot of 30 of 30 rock episode
where uh jack donaghy took all of the
seinfeld episodes because they own the
likeness of jerry seinfeld and
superimposed him into other shows
so they would take it was actually and
then jerry seinfeld finds out he gets
really mad so we need to rewrite it oh
it's really really funny because i love
the show
jerry seinfeld finds out and he's like
uh he's like i could buy your network
ten times over and then jack's like you
don't have four million dollars left
we're going to need to rewrite
entertainment law really rapidly too
because i don't think corporations
should own the likeness to actors
anymore because of the deep fake meta
net that we're entering that's
interesting that's that's actually a
really good point you know i've been
excited about
these technological advances because of
star trek the animated series which is
that's an old one
but here's here's the thing that
occurred to me recently is that some of
the best star trek writing and this the
third season of the original series of
star trek is garbage the first season is
some of the best sci-fi ever written and
the animated series
is some of the best sci-fi that was ever
written and it occurred to me very
recently after the next generation yeah
we're moments away
from them making live action versions of
star trek the animated series with the
original cast it's already their voices
they voiced the animated characters and
now
a remake
an animated remake would essentially be
deep fake level
reality right they can just make that
show now and they can put jerry seinfeld
in it and then jerry seinfeld will show
up
so
we've had this
so it'd be like a basic human right is
you own the ip to your likeness forever
henceforth but i think there's an
argument today unless you trade it for
some ethereum i think yeah if you need
ethereum no i'm not saying this is the
argument i would make but someone who is
in favor of people being able to
redistribute their likeness would say
well you own it therefore you have a
right to sell it so you could sell it to
a network maybe that's what we're
looking at maybe you're not illegally
allowed to sell it but maybe license it
for uh with a sunset clause i mean i
mean just ready player one have you guys
seen it or i ready
yeah people people were cartoon
characters they they would go into the
game and they'd make themselves whatever
they wanted you know and in fact in that
movie there was a one of one of the
in-game characters a dude was actually a
woman in real life
it's not that they're it's not that like
the gnostic heresy version of the
metaverse won't come to pass it will
yeah
but there but there will also be there
there's also a beauty to be found in the
future we we have to go build it we
we are not victims of circumstance the
worst thing to be
as a human is someone who who perceives
themselves as powerless uh perceives
themselves only to be a victim of sort
of the fates around them right
we
we can go make it we can make it better
we can answer some of these questions in
advance we can build structures that
constrain some of the worst excesses
that could come to pass but we won't
we'll just say 30 years later that we
should have had our own i think we will
we'll build this metaverse with free
software so that you can see the uh the
algorithm codes and you know if it's
extracting your thoughts or not and then
you'll be able to pass it up and create
new meta-nets that will all interoperate
and you'll have like an open system
babies will be born and the doctor will
say to the parents do you want the we
can do the uh neurolink implant today we
can do it right now while your baby's in
the other room and they'll say oh yeah
yeah absolutely i mean truth be told
what will likely happen is they'll call
you on the phone and be like hello mr
johnson your test tube baby was born and
we did the neurolink implant you can
pick them up at five by click
the next generation is the opposite of
the original series because the first
season sucks and the third season starts
to be good i think the kids are better
and better
don't you don't think the first season
it introduces q that is absurd it was
awkwardly acted i thought that that is
absurd it's funny it all started the
best of both worlds is the greatest
achievement in the history of television
until game of thrones
and after the best and after yeah and
after the best of both worlds it becomes
a great television show that's an
episode the best of both worlds it's two
episodes um which one is locutis of borg
yeah oh my goodness yeah yeah borg was
such a good episode
it's unbelievable and after that you
know they they brought the high collar
in they got the cooler phasers they got
the new model everything got cool but
man those first couple seasons it's the
love boat in space
this is this is this is our western
canyon
the future generations need to know star
trek disney
because there are so many people who are
naysayers
i'm i'm surprised there are people who
would watch a show like this but also be
like i'm not watching star trek
yeah and i'm just like no no you don't
understand we're not talking about
wouldn't it be cool to be in a spaceship
with lasers we're talking about
naval tradition we're talking about
military officers defending of the
freedom and civil liberties of
individuals going to planets where they
experience terrorism the uh that line uh
when data goes to picard and says i'm
having trouble understanding you know
the conduct of these people they're
engaging in terrorism and then picard
says i do not uh subscribe to the belief
that political power is derived from the
barrel of a gun and then data says but
if you look at history and the names
like two real examples but then
fictional future examples where terror
actually worked and picard's like these
are questions that humanity struggles
with like that's why the show is good
yeah the philosophical and moral
explorations and i was being somewhat
facetious but there is a component to
the fact that star trek did often
include the great work so they
referenced shakespeare you have episodes
about you know greek mythology they
really included things that today most
people are completely unaware of which
is sad but you could actually like learn
about them from star trek and then start
to do a deep dive because kids aren't
learning it in school that's right yeah
i do have a special soft spot for like
laser beams though when they like rough
house with an alien you know that
costume i do too one of my least
favorite things about all the new
iterations of star trek starting with
the jj abrams and all the way through
picard right now is that they've
basically gotten rid of phasers and
everything's just a star wars style
blaster now
man they call them phasers but they
don't have beams they're like little
bubbles they were little clickers the uh
in the next generation they were
miniaturized little clickers they would
just point which would be very difficult
to aim oh yeah you couldn't i think
every time i watch the next generation i
just think you just killed everybody
yeah you'll see like what is this i
wonder if they own themselves that yeah
well one of the things that was positive
about it and the reason uh my dad used
to watch it with us as kids is because
his view he told us when we got older is
that it was very much a positive
influence because
they would exhaust every peaceful option
they could but they would still fight
when they had to so it wasn't completely
pacifist but they were all about seeking
the non-violent solution when possible
and they didn't hesitate in the face of
of threat they would fight immediately
they would fight when they needed to
yeah
the original series was so pro-american
i grew up in the next generation i love
the next generation right i'm a sucker
for all star trek
but the original series is
like morally and philosophically so much
better because it's deeper and richer it
was at the height of real sci-fi
especially the first season and a half
where they really were asking all these
questions for the first time and you
have these episodes where like
captain kirk will beam down to a planet
that is utopia everyone there has all
the food they can eat they have it never
rains you know there's no hail there's
no weather everything is perfect and
he'll look around and say this place is
crap i'm gonna go i'm gonna go destroy
the computer that has made you all
mental slaves yeah and he'll go to he'll
ruin their utopia to set them free and
you you talk about things you can't do
on television now you could never say
that utopia is bad because people aren't
free that's so true that's interesting
this is what people have pointed out
have you been following the new picard
oh yeah of course uh
i don't think i'm gonna watch i yeah i i
didn't even bother i didn't mind season
one of picard um but season two for
those that aren't aware is about uh you
know what is it the 2022's or whatever
the 2020 yeah 20 20 22 20's or whatever
2024. 20
well so the star trek crew picard which
are in the future have to transport
themselves back in time to 2024 because
something happened that turned earth
into a human supremacist planet right
and i'm just like yo
this is the stupidest thing i have ever
political propaganda it's absolutely
absurd by the way and i've seen i've
seen every episode that's out so far i
can't help myself but
i'm such a sucker for nostalgia
and the first season of picard is
terrible but when you get to the end and
we get the actual data picard death
scene that we were robbed of in the
films you go yeah i'll follow you guys
through the gates of hell give me tell
me how all humans are fascists i'm in i
want to i want to know yeah they never
talk about vulcan supremacists it's
interesting but vulcans don't have
institutional powers so they're not the
first thing is it's clear that the
picard series is just you know member
berries
remember the borg remember pick up and
then like they meet everyone and it's
like oh like yo just give me a series
that follows deep space nine in in the
continuity and we can move beyond the
dominion or whatever for those that are
fans and uh but instead what they're
doing is
we're going back in time again
and the the characters they bring back
you know so uh you've watched the first
two episodes i'd imagine of picard first
four yeah first four already out man
i've been working too much um but q does
not feel like you you know when when
he's like this is not a lesson picard
it's penance i'm like come on he was the
guy who showed up with the mariachi band
smoking a cigar and dancing not some
like torture of some great message or
anything he's just exotic yeah you're
nuts with him you're not you're not
allowed to have fun right this is what's
different now you're not allowed every
everything you watch ads at the super
bowl uh and they're all they're all
important the words you would use for
the the ad agent they would say this was
an important ad at the super bowl or
this was a beautiful ad to the super
bowl or this was a touching ad at the
super bowl yeah but what are the really
funny ads at the super bowl i'm getting
people keep writing in telling me that
the jeremy's razor shameless plug uh unc
died i hate harry.com
commercial
people
hundreds of people are writing it this
is the best commercial i've ever seen
i'm very proud of the commercial it's
not the best commercial that's ever been
made why they're responding that way is
because it is the best commercial that's
been made in a decade because it's the
first commercial in a decade where you
can just laugh at it and that's good and
my fault like what's that movie fall guy
is that what it is with ryan ryan
reynolds fall guy is that what it's
called no is that what the movie's
called which one when some movie that
just came out where's the prize free guy
free guy he's a free guy not like a free
guy but like well like almost like
produced like on that level and then i
just want to add you know
my uh compliments to uh the commercial
were so good the daily wire actually uh
picked that one up pushed my video out
you know because because you know yeah
well good commentary from tim yeah we
need more like that you mentioned these
uh these people seeing their
advertisements as important and this is
one of these things that if they could
just step out of their little box for
three seconds they would understand how
ridiculous it is just the phrase like
this is going to be the most important
coca-cola commercial but let me let me i
want to go back to uh let's back to star
trek
how and why does a network a company say
we have this this ip this popular ip we
have decades of storytelling and movies
and series
let's just put them in 2024 to fight
trump i know why that's nothing to do
with any of the history like if you want
to make a show about time travelers who
fight donald trump make the show i i'd
probably watch it anyway just to see
what you're talking about but why make
picard do it and they and then star trek
discovery stacy abrams shows up as the
president of united earth
wow oh she actually got cheated out of
that election who are they speaking to
themselves they're speaking to
themselves i honestly wonder if they're
even doing that it's funny we were oh
man i really wanted to get into this
earlier but it blew past that so now is
the perfect time to segue to it you were
discussing the the western canon and
part of why it's so important to tell
good stories is because it's where
people get their morality from yes it
helps to give people moral precepts and
principles but ultimately people are
going to act on the basis of who they
admire and the stories that they know
and so part of why they need to change
these stories is because though they
weren't perfect some of them actually
had decent values and so what you need
to do is wreck retcon them and shove
your own values into it so that you can
control people this is what people say
because i tweeted a video from uh the
next generation
where uh
the the the uh an admiral starfleet
orders data to give up his child to the
you know the state and picard is like no
and he risks his career he says men of
good conscience will defy orders
you know to watch to have to to compel a
man to give his child to the state not
while i'm captain and i was like man
that was so awesome and then everyone
said the new picard series he would do
the opposite he would say for the for
the betterment of the family we must
allow you know and and for safety and
security that's what that's that's the
message we'd get across now from picard
like his values are gone yeah and that's
kind of sad to me the character should
have been left left just as as as it was
but they can't they can't do it they
can't they need to take it because they
can't create they can't make new things
they have to pervert what other people
have already done
this is true which is why
they take this long historic this this
long history
history show and then change it but it's
also they want to destroy the the
character picard represented the values
he represented they want to take him
away as a role model from people who
believed in these civil libertarian
values this is one of the reasons that
we got into making movies at daily wires
because so much content that exists now
exists to tell you that you don't
deserve
these characters and so like you know
you see it in these superhero movies uh
quite a lot like you watch the beginning
of uh in game and captain america who in
the first in the first avengers movie
captain america says you know there's
only one god and he doesn't wear tights
and he's he's a character from the 1940s
yep
who goes to
lies about his age to go fight the nazis
he wears red white and blue and
literally is called america that's the
character and he gets frozen in ice and
he wakes up in the 20th century and by
in game it opens up and he's in this
counseling session and we have to have
the reveal that the person who is
sharing an insight with him is a married
gay man a gay married gay man i would
say a gay married gay man because gay
men have been married throughout all of
human history and it didn't mean what we
mean now right uh it's a gay married gay
man and what why do they do why do that
you say well it's to be inclusive is to
show people that even gay married gay
men have a place in the world but that's
not why they do it if that's why they
did it i might even go okay we can live
that isn't the motive the motive is to
say
all of you red state flyover maga hat
wearin
love america wear red white and blue
guys
literal captain america doesn't belong
to you you don't get to claim him he
belongs to us we can give him any set of
values that we want in fact if you watch
that whole marvel avengers arc
remarkably
captain america
becomes the uh the renegade character
during civil war and iron man tony stark
becomes the representative of state
power like it's a it's an unbelievable
inversion of those characters because
they don't know what the characters mean
it's not because they don't know it's
because they actually really check with
the characters hold on are you you're
not familiar with the captain america
nomad arc i'm not no captain america
uh i don't i'm not i haven't read all
this stuff it was before my time but
there was a period where captain america
abandoned the name and called himself
nomad because you know the point they
were making was if you truly believe in
america you don't always stand by the
government for whatever it does sure so
you know that's a general idea i
actually thought civil war was fairly
well done i mean captain america was the
guy saying
i'm not going to sign over my rights to
the state i'm you know i'm an individual
and tony stark is is a corporate war
monger who's like
the state you know is right science i
know you know we have to
i thought the the the politics in that
were were fairly good albeit the marvel
movies are like kindergarten grade
entertainment yeah captain america's uh
war propaganda was created to fight
nazis and get people right about world
war ii and keep that in mind forever
moving forward that was war propaganda
well i want to make this point part of
why it's so instructive that is captain
america is because the left has this
fetish for protect projecting their
values onto the people who fought the
second world war so they're always
claiming that they're the ones fighting
nazi uh you'll see memes floating around
of the brave young men storming normandy
and it says this is antifa trying to
fight nazis um i did a cartoon about
this a while ago called fighting nazis
then verse now and what it was based on
was this exact premise because my
grandfather fought in the second world
war he
played a very key role in in ensuring
that the
officers at the flossenberg
concentration camp were
caught and placed on trial he really had
an
incredible and harrowing tour
and he would not use your pronouns i
mean this is not somebody who's going to
uh or would you make applies with
left-wing valleys yeah exactly i made a
whole cartoon about this point but it's
so funny to me that the left wants to
claim that they own these people even
though if if they were alive today and
those who are alive today from that era
don't agree with them at all if they
even think about them yeah yeah i wonder
if um
the speed at which we're communicating
the bifurcation of culture will just
it's leading to
something some say peaceful divorce
perhaps because of the internet it could
be something we haven't seen in the past
or civil war maybe but i just don't see
how
there's any reconciliation with the the
modern iteration of the polit the left
sphere of influence because the things
they believe
are just not aligned with reason i think
it comes to the individual clearing like
having slowing down their thoughts
because if your mind is moving super
rapidly with the information like a car
traveling so fast on the road a minor
uh variation in the wheel will send that
thing flying off course and the same
thing happens to your brain if it's on
overload activity all the time so it's
really
i don't think there's a top-down
solution it'll be up to people to
control themselves and let this stuff
flow past them while still acknowledging
it
are we doomed or is it going to be all
right i don't think we're getting both i
think things get bad for a while i think
things might get bad for a while i
wouldn't say that we're doomed though i
don't i mean it's pretty it's a pretty
easy prediction to say that things are
going to get bad for a while but also in
the long run i don't know how things are
going to turn out
my mentality is very much like i got to
be honest with everybody um
you know i had it bad most of my life
you know up until my mid 20s when you
know for the next you know a few years
my career started taking off and things
started generally improving and so for
me my editor's always kind of just been
like yo all of this is icing on the cake
you know if if if people were unwilling
to fight for their values and their va
and everything fell apart
the food shortages get really bad and i
wake up you know in six months homeless
and with no food i'd be like oh you know
been there done that i'm not really
worried about it granted i don't have a
family so a lot of people who do would
be much more terrified of something like
that if tomorrow all the things were
gone i'd worked for all my life oh yeah
if you had to start again with just your
children and your wife
oh here we go
no i just there's a i think it was
zoobee who said this that if you took
all of the property for from every
single person
and then gave everyone you know ten
thousand dollars the people who were
rich before would become rich and the
people who were poor before would would
become poor for the most part this is a
hard conversation maybe we can go to the
after show because it really comes down
to eugenics like this this concept of
eugenics where it came from and what it
all means like the fact that people even
think of themselves as an elite class
and that there's everybody else and that
or or the plebeians is what the romans
called them and then there's the central
intelligentsia i don't know is that real
like we just like you just stated well a
lot of things are real a lot of things
that are unseemly are real but not
everything that's real is is um
not everything that's true is capital t
truth like i think that one of the
problems this kind of comes back to the
ideology dogma thing we we sometimes
take observations that we make
or measurements that we make things that
are true and because you're not allowed
to say a lot of things that are true in
our culture right now
it's it's uh subversive to even think
about them and the result the result of
that is that whenever you do engage with
those ideas you're engaging in them in
the worst places possible with people
who are like
probably taking them to the furthest
extreme and it becomes easy for us to so
you know like you become a eugenicist in
your mind like hitler was in the 20s and
30s or something which is
obviously a grave evil thing i mean it's
it's obviously true
it's an obvious truth that simply
because something is generally true it's
not specifically true that because uh
for example
asian americans have a higher iq than
than white americans just to avoid any
of the races you're not allowed to talk
about
there's nothing racist about talking ill
of asians right so asians statistically
higher iq than white people that that
the smartest person in the world could
be a white person uh and it would still
be true that statistically the
statistically agents have a higher iq so
you end up in a situation where the the
truth about the general truth
can sometimes blind us to the specific
truth
and that's where i think that's where a
lot of tribalism a lot of isms come from
that that aren't good you get into the
nuance of what is what does it mean to
be asian are you referring specifically
to like southeast asian are you
referring to the philippines are
referring to india of course and then
those things all play a role i think the
problem with stereotypes is that people
hear the word asian they exclude indians
but particularly in europe you say the
word asian and they include indians so
we're not even you know we're not even
necessarily hitting at the same points
yeah i agree i i'm only making the point
that when we talk about these difficult
issues like eugenics uh are some people
are some people born with advantages of
course they are people are born with
high iqs and people are born with low
iqs more people are born with low iqs
than people are born with high iqs one
of the challenges in in
ordering society is not letting is not
judging people based on those
generalities but that doesn't mean that
there aren't specific
realities that people
that people are different there are
people born with advantages you can
leave iq out of it iq is the hardest
thing to talk about because everyone is
the smartest person they know it's just
your your own your ability to perceive
someone smarter than you is capped by
your own intelligence
but it's very easy for me to acknowledge
that like lebron james is better than
basketball than i am and you could say
if i practiced really hard i could be
better than no i couldn't if i practiced
really hard i could be better than me
but no amount of practice will make me
better than lebron if lebron didn't
practice
and i did practice he would still be
better than me now
if we played a game of
uh
lebron and i play a game of pig and
instead of playing pig we just play puh
and lebron says whoever wins this game
of puh you know gets a million dollars
station i might win the million dollars
every now and then he misses and every
now and then i don't
but if you make it pit
his chances go up exponential
exponentially if you make it pig they go
up even radically if you make it hoarse
i will never win statistically ever
there's no world where i will ever win
that he has those advantages there's no
question about those advantages let's go
to super chats if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
if you really do like it you want to
help us out and go to timcast.com sign
up to become a member to support our
work and we're going to have a members
only segment going live on the website
around 11 or so p.m you're not going to
want to miss it it'll be fun but let's
read some super chats all right we got
rylo who says applebee's is celebrating
inflation because it kills competition
and makes people poor they know that
more poor people means more disposable
employees they can underpay and overwork
applebee's hates you i'm not familiar
with that is that something specific i
didn't hear anything about that yeah i
don't know maybe this guy just got fired
by apple maybe what if they just like
really don't like applebee's yeah i
don't know what happened i'm gonna
google this now
all right patriot american says happy
birthday to my fellow irish-american
brother sheamus oh thank you for the
good work bro thank you very much oh you
guys are so nice
we uh i worked really really hard to
make a cake for seamus it was insane it
was it was really incredible it's
honoring
his irish heritage yeah that's right i
drew gold coins that's what the redskins
said they put the shamrocks on it
and i wrote mcbirthday he did yeah
birthday that means son of birthday it's
just racist
and this is a great everyone here is
irish this is a great way of looking
back to the problem with stereotyping
that no you know if if i take a shot and
he takes a shot uh statistically i could
become the alcoholic
but if there's three shots
also i'm a writer too so like irish plus
writer i'm in even worse shape out yeah
game over i just i think the joke's
funny because sheamus is an american guy
from the south side yeah exactly exactly
we're constantly coming spent most of my
life in the suburbs let's be real you
know i mean i can't take all that street
cred
all right grayson says it's not just
about building culture you have a
culture and history already you need to
make people proud of the history and
culture they already are a part of not
forget it and do something else
that's true yeah i think it's true i
don't think it's all the i don't think
that's enough but that is a major part
of it and it's a part that we haven't
talked about much tonight so i think
it's it's good that they point it out
american advocate says i'm so proud of
the daily wire they're not afraid of
conversation or debate the biggest
cajones in america i'm all in latinos
for america oh there you go wow that's
amazing uh thank you
um we we take it as a responsibility but
i'll also say we're just having a good
time too and i think that uh that's part
of what differentiates the daily wires
that we enjoy what we do man my thing is
like have fun if you're not having fun
you're doing it wrong point yeah
all right hayden says jeremy i'm from
the lubb area thanks for what you've
built you hate credentialism my question
is how would you recommend somebody get
started in learning about video
production working at daily wire has
become a goal is spc and option they've
gone woke yep uh i went to spc for for a
period of time uh i i didn't ever go to
a university i didn't get a college
degree i didn't even get an associate's
degree
and i failed at everything that i did in
life basically until i was 35 i'd never
made more than 25 000 in a year in
personal income i
had businesses that made more money than
that i just paid it to other people
and and didn't understand how to pay
myself and as a result i had
disconnected
my own um my own personal success from
the success of these entities i had
created sort of a false
and and crippling moral paradigm for
myself and obviously now i'm
spectacularly wealthy and people bow to
me and call me
all god so so my my first thing as a guy
from uh from the lubbock area as a guy
who went to spc uh i just want to
encourage you that
it doesn't matter what advantages you
start life with it doesn't matter what
advantages uh come your way you can you
can make of life what you will you can
you can set your mind to something and
you can go accomplish it that's not true
for everyone in every place it is true
if you're born in this country the proof
is all around you opportunity is
everywhere
you just have to learn grow challenge
yourself never be complacent don't stand
still
don't be risk-averse if you want
security you can have it but if you want
the kind of success
that you're describing you actually have
to go risk for it now as to how does one
get the small steps how's one get into
video production how does one get uh
even a job at the daily wire i think
that there is there's no substitute in
life for doing
there are those in life who do and there
are those who do not and this is my
famed jeremy's do doers and do
naughter's speech no one has ever been
happy to receive it no one is ever
satisfied they'll say how do you do thus
and such i give this speech they always
think there's more there isn't more
there are those who do and there are
those who do not when i moved to
hollywood i thought i'm a smart guy
if i just met steven spielberg and he
could tell me how to make a movie
i could take that and go make a movie
and then it was only after years of
struggling in hollywood that i came to
realize that steven spielberg
if he if i did get that meeting what
would he tell me he would say oh you
want to know how to make a movie no
problem find a book written by a famous
author that you really like that sold a
lot of copies give him a million dollars
for a two-year option on that book
then go take meetings with 10 of the
best writers in the world pay one of
them a million dollars to write a draft
you won't like the draft so you'll pay
the second guy on the list half a
million dollars to rewrite the draft
when you have a draft that you like call
your buddy tom cruise and say would you
like to play the lead in this he'll say
yeah and i'll be over for burgers this
weekend
now you've got him go to your business
partners at your own studio that you own
have them architect the foreign sales
deal piece of this and then go to the
major studio with whom you have a direct
distribution deal and trick and trigger
it and they'll release it now now you
can make your movie what good would that
information do me if i had it
the real question the real question you
want to ask is
steven spielberg how should how could i
make a movie and the answer to that
would be oh i have no idea it's com
steven spielberg knows less about how
you could be successful than anyone what
you should do instead is realize that
how did steven spielberg himself did it
well he just did it yeah he's just he
was a he was a those who do not aid
those who do not that's what i tell
people because one of the most
frustrating things i hear all the time
is either tim you're able to do things
because you have money and i'm like it's
the inversion it's the other way around
it's because i did things i have money
and people saying if only i had money i
could do thing and i'm like that's just
not true i've seen it i worked for a
fusion they put hundreds of millions of
dollars into nothing flush down the
toilet money doesn't make things happen
people do so whenever people are like
how do i do something how do i do i'm
like you just do it you like like how do
i film these videos i don't have a
computer i have cameras i don't know
stuff like give a phone you do most
people do if you don't truth be told
maybe you don't but
phones you can get an android phone for
no joke like 20 to 30 bucks not a good
one you can get a webcam for 20 to 30
bucks you can go stand in a street
corner in any major city and hold up a
sign saying once i get 20 bucks i'm
gonna buy a webcam to start a show
that's all i need and in 10 minutes i
guarantee you someone will walk over and
hand you 20 bucks that is american
privilege because we do that
i'm not saying it's the best thing to do
but how about this you go work for a
fast food restaurant
you work until you make save up a couple
couple hundred bucks to buy a computer
and a camera and then you can start
making videos and then you just have to
earn it you know the idea that people
are going to watch your content it's got
to be earned you know i was just talking
about this band i knew a long time ago
me and uh we were driving in a car we
were listening to this old music
and you know someone said what happened
to him i'm like they broke up because
the lead singer was like if my music was
so good how come i'm not famous and then
i was like bro you can't just write a
song and then think you're going to be
famous like you've got to work for 10
years you've got to keep playing you've
got to do you've got to put in so much
work and effort i got started doing all
of this stuff technically well before i
was 25 because i was working at
nonprofits i was involved in politics i
was reading the news all day every day
since i was 15. so when occupy wall
street started i went to cover it i
already knew a lot about what had been
going on this allowed me to you know
it's all one thing after another but
let's uh let's let's read some more
super chats yeah
i love that story and this to me nothing
we've talked about tonight is more
important than this i
we've hit on it in several different
ways but this idea that you're just a
victim of your circumstances is the is
the most crippling the victim mentality
is the most crippling ideology that has
ever been unleashed on an individual
you
again not everywhere there are people
born in true hardship around the world
in this country you can do so i love
gary vaynerchuk for this reason i love
that on saturdays he goes out and buys
crap at garage sales and then sells it
and shows that you anyone could have
done what he just did you know the story
of the guy who traded the paper clip for
a house right that's right and but
several people have replicated this in
various ways he a guy took a paper clip
and he traded it up and up and on
craigslist and or whatever the story was
paper clip for a pen pen for a notepad
notepad for a pack of pens eventually he
got to a lawn mower then a bike then a
then a broken motorcycle eventually it
was a boat and then sooner or later he
traded for an old house got the deed
from a paper clip because the difference
between a piece of paper and a million
dollar screenplay is what comes out of
your brain and goes onto that page
that's it let's read some more
all right david short says hey tim just
bought my first 10 chicks please ask
jeremy where the razors are made
that's a
non-sequitur yeah it is
our razors are made in china we source
them through finland there are no razors
made in america interesting
razors are not made in america we
listen one of the reasons it took us a
year to get our razor out
is because we were trying to source
razors it's a very challenging thing a
razor is a thing that cuts people yes so
a lot of people don't want to make them
there are there are
straight razors made in america there
aren't cartridge razors made in america
we haven't talked about this much
publicly a lot of people will write into
me all the time and say because i'm
conservative and they'll be like oh you
make your leftist tears tumblers in
china i'm canceling and i always think
you wrote that on a computer or a phone
that was made in china i don't
understand it's not i didn't decide to
export all of america's manufacturing
jobs overseas that happened when i was a
child this is the world that i live in i
want to change that world but
the reality of how to change that world
is it takes time success and money just
our leftist tears tumbler is a great
example we have priced out what it would
cost to manufacture the tumblers in
america just the equipment would cost 20
million dollars so the cost of a tumbler
would go from 20 per tumbler not to
people say you just do it to save a few
cents or a few bucks no no the cost of
the tumbler would go from 20
to
200 per tumbler in raw material like or
which means like
it is it's not impossible it is
it is practically impossible it is not
that actually is prohibitively uh now
will we ever make our razors in america
will we ever make our tumblers in
america well i'm telling you what it
would cost to make the tumblers in
america because i know because we're
always researching how to change the
paradigm where all of our manufacturing
is is overseas we do think that we have
a constructive role to play in that but
it's a role that one can only play out
of success we've talked to our friends
over at black rifle coffee for example
about
buying tumbler making equipment together
starting a joint venture it's going to
it takes real resources it takes real
success to make these razors in america
four days ago i did not own a razor
company today i've sold 25 000 razer
subscriptions like that to do that
requires
buying razors where they already make
razors if if we sell a million razer
subscriptions we'll build a razor
company in america and we'll change
things and by the way if we get a
million subscribers it won't just be our
razors that are made in america once we
build the infrastructure to make razors
in america
other companies will come source razors
from us so it's not that i'm
opposed to the where is this made
question i'm what i what i kind of get i
get a little bit out of shape about this
because i think people don't really
understand
how how much we have exported overseas
in terms of manufacturing everything how
much money and time it's going to take
to fix that and to think that well you
shouldn't be able to start
a if you're a real american you wouldn't
even start a company until you could
make the razors in america would just
mean that you can't make anything
i want to eventually manufacture things
in america which we will do in success
absolutely i love that people think you
know a lot of people i saw on twitter
were saying like i can't believe the
daily wire would do this uh and i'm just
like do you i wonder if do you think
that you like the daily wire guys aren't
thinking about that when they you know
why are they making that in china it's
like i'm pretty sure they know what
people are going to say if they do and
why they have to yeah like these
microphones were made in china and these
laptops were made in china that gorilla
was made in china like it's going to
take time to change
let's see what he says here that's
definitely chinese there's never this
one has is that chinese on the packaging
i don't know this is this is a gift from
luke owski that is chinese yeah yeah
luke's it's definitely part of the
sent sent a birthday present made in
china
we uh
yeah we should change it yeah this is
the generational world to change it you
wanna know the craziest thing tell me
how they make skateboards
wood from canada
gets shipped to the us
then shipped to china turned into a
skateboard and ship back to the us yeah
that sounds like the stupidest thing
i've ever heard a lot of people are
talking about chinese labor is so cheap
that it's cheaper to ship all of that
wood all over the place than just make
it here in the u.s it's also the epa
very famously steve jobs said only a
year or two before he died
he said if we had not been able to make
the iphone if i had been required to
make the iphone in america just the
process of innovating around the class
for the for the screen on the iphone he
said
i don't remember what iphone we were on
when steve jobs died iphone 6 or iphone
6s or something he said we would not be
at iphone one yet yeah if i had to make
it in america and that's because of
environmental laws and you can say
environmental laws that steve jobs
supported yeah i'm not i'm not hey i'm
giving you a steve jobs say geography
i'm just telling you if a guy worth
billions and billions and billions of
dollars couldn't manufacture in america
have a little grace for those of us who
are trying to start things from the
ground up mike allen says if you joined
late and are listening at 1.5 times
speed to catch up jeremy sounds like ben
shapiro oh oh that's the nicest thing
anyone's ever said about me
all right josh oh my gosh says how the
frick can i get an acting job with the
daily wire i need a job i can enjoy i'm
an entertainer and i can't stand
hollywood please let jeremy know i will
send my resume to him
yeah
look we need talent um
one of the challenges in our in our work
is because we're very front-facing
because we're very public
a lot of people you know ask us for jobs
and obviously you can't hire everyone
who asks you for a job but we are
looking for real talent we're looking
for real talent in our entertainment
business we're looking for real talent
in the manufacturing and distribution of
consumer goods business which
suddenly we have
we're looking for real executive and
leadership and management talent at the
daily wire scaling of business is
incredibly hard everything about
being successful is hard there's a great
line in an episode of breaking bad when
the villain is making soup and he says
to walter white
you must learn to be rich to be poor
anyone can manage and it's true
everyone knows how to fail you have to
learn how to succeed and you have to
keep learning how to succeed success can
lead you to destruction just as quickly
as failure can uh and so at every turn
as we grow this business we need talent
so please you know reach
careers at daily wire
send us your resume send us your uh send
us your um
whether you're in entertainment or in
business or whatever we need good talent
when it comes to acting i feel like the
industry's changed and that the resume
had shot things done now and that i what
i want to see is that and i want to see
the real yeah i want to see video of
them yeah go do something you're you're
uh your your story is that uh you you
failed up until you know you're 35 is
that what it was or what was like you
weren't making a lot of money and then
all of a sudden you started being
successful the the started the daily
wire actually it was the the first time
that i ever made more than 25 000 in a
year was at the precursor company that
ben and i had called truth revolt and i
got a nice salary and at that time
prager you started paying me
a nice salary as well so i
was not a salary but a nice consulting
fee
and so i was suddenly making you know
six figures for the first time in my
life as a 35 year old man
uh and
it really is amazing how just that
change of mind that ben
uh and my friend frank helped me achieve
unlocked
all of the actual power of economic
incentive and between in between 35 and
43 i mean i flew here on a private plane
to do your show today wow
so uh you're the one percent
and um
were you shocked when you realized the
laws limiting how you could spend money
once you got large sums of money oh yeah
yeah this is i bring this up because
i can't tell you how many conversations
i've had with people when they say
things like hey why don't you just do
this or that with your company i'm like
that's illegal and they're like what
right and i'm like you can't just do
that with money
there's limitations there's financial
limitations there's laws there's tax
restrictions there's tax holding
requirements all this crazy stuff you
can't just you can't just you can't even
just give someone money no you can't
give people money everybody's like if
you gave me a if i gave you a million i
can't give you a million dollars even if
i had a million dollars to give you the
other thing people don't uh that they
don't understand is that when you are in
a rapid ascent
the way that people of means are taxed
is different i don't pay taxes on april
15th i pay taxes every quarter right and
those taxes are based on projections of
earnings that the irs has rules about
and so there have been times over these
last seven years where i was making an
incredible amount of money on paper
but i was giving so much money to the
government that i didn't know how i was
going to pay my mortgage yeah like it's
unbelievable how they take that money
from and if you make a lot of money in
one year or one quarter and then all of
a sudden covet hits and and revenues
drop dramatically they're like we still
expect your projections you've got to
pay you've got to pay as a percentage of
last year's
success well the government's job is to
control the economy and giving it to the
federal reserve is blatant disrespect
for
if you want rep if you want to represent
me and you want my tax money you better
represent me and not outsource the
representation to a private company
let's let's uh get sorry but we gotta i
want to try and get more super chats in
uh cd stein says ask jeremy if they
would consider also starting a book
publishing company that includes comics
since the rise of insane wokeness in the
big 2 2 of comics yeah well we have
started a book publishing company dw
publishing our first book
is with sergeant mattingly and is out
now
we have a couple of other really good
books that are going to come out our
first release was actually what is a
walrus by matt walsh which was a
children's board book but our first uh
our first
adult publication is mattingly's book um
we we signed a
great book deal with jonathan isaac the
nba player which we're really proud
about and and you know that guy
uh that guy stood up when other people
were kneeling and and were proud to be
in business with him and we have uh
only in the last four weeks we have seen
the first boards for a graphic novel
that we're working on so this is
something that we're pursuing we're not
pursuing it with the same sort of
aggressive vigor that we are
our entertainment play it's a place
where i would say we're testing
um not not not that we're uh charging
it's not a hill we're charging it's a
place where we're testing but uh
obviously we think the creation of ip
the creation of comics the creation of
graphic novels creation of fiction you
know again one of the things that makes
us different from other conservative
companies even in publishing is that
we're not just going to publish a bunch
of non-fiction i have a really great
idea for a children's book it's called
the donkey who cried bear
it's about a family a a village of
donkeys and one donkey keeps screaming
the bears are coming the bears are
controlling our donkey president you
know yeah yeah but but then what
happened i'm actually kidding what
happens at the end
i thought there's invaded
did you uh what's the what's the model
like the cost model for daily wire right
now for you for someone that wants to
subscribe to the network yeah i mean
head over to dailywire.com subscribe and
become a member the there's a couple of
different tiers whoa whoa whoa use promo
code tim pool to get 25 off use promo
code tim pool to get 25 is that a real
promo code yeah i would like to say to
any of my staff listening please quickly
turn on a promo code called tim no no uh
because uh daily wire had a sponsor uh
sponsored two of our shows this month oh
that's right there is a promo code
temple 25 off heck yeah and then you get
access to all the movies on the network
and all the graphic novels when you
subscribe
yes you well not the gra there are no
graphic novels yet in existence but yes
you you get the bench press show candace
owen show michael knowles uh if you want
him matt walsh also andrew clay
you get the feature film shut in the
hyperions run hide fight so truly like a
netflix similar to a netflix model at
this stage exactly so we have a question
here from but instead of having every
movie ever created we have run hide
fight shut in and hyperion
yeah hyperions is out the hyperions is
out i definitely watch that it's
fabulous uncle d says will the daily
wire make cartoons and a streaming
service we won't need disney hulu or
netflix well we know you're doing a
streaming service but are you doing
cartoons well it was in uh
it was reported today that ben shapiro
said the daily wire is going to move
into kids content
um i
i had to call ben and say ben don't say
things like that we're not ready yet
we're not ready yet
but it is it is true that we are in
development on kids content and it's
definitely our hope uh that in 2023 we
can bring some great kids content to the
market
spidge b says you need to jam with
jeremy he's quite an accomplished
musician yes ah well i'm not i i am
quite accomplished what i'm not is very
good
i say i'm accomplished because smokey
mike and the god king played to a
sold-out house at the mother church of
country music the ryman auditorium wow
but but you should never mistake that
for talent which i have i have very
fleeting michael knowles he's really
good michael's a great guitar player
yeah he thinks i cannot believe i'm
hearing compliments of michael nolan's
right now right it's unbelievable it's
disturbing
only in the context of smokey mike in
the god king will i say anything next
only as long as your ego gets a
compliment well it's his group he's got
a compliment
tough break all right andrew lance says
god king i've been a dw all access
member for as long as possible
get with sheamus and give us our freedom
tunes animated series already
uh i
when i sat down
sheamus said you know what what would
you like to talk about at our meeting in
in two weeks and i said i didn't i don't
know honestly i didn't know we had a
meeting in two weeks that was actually
really really funny but that is
apparently a thing that's happening and
i couldn't i'm stoked about it uh i love
freedom tunes thank you uh ben shapiro
shooting lasers out of his eyes was a
turning point
honestly okay it's something i actually
do every now and again so the fact that
he put in a cartoon is really
revolutionary people you know ben
shapiro reacting
freedom tunes ben shapiro reacting to
real ben shapiro reacting to freedom
tunes was good yeah so ben shapiro
reacted to my cartoon of him and then i
did a cartoon of cartoon venture peer
reacting to a real venture pair reacting
to the cartoon or ben shapiro's family
thanksgiving was it honestly it was one
of the best yeah thanksgiving thank you
i love that one he tweeted it it's funny
because right after i made it i uh put
it on twitter and then he retweeted it
and said this is a documentary
did he really yeah yeah he said this
talked about he or he i i tweeted the
link at him and he posted the link and
said this is a documentary fox that's
awesome i have been to a family dinner
or two at ben's home with his entire
family and it is not unlike
i knew it perfect
all right chris stark says tim and crew
you should read milton friedman
unraveled by murray rothbard
it helps to explain his role as to why
we are in the current economic situation
uh and and some well worth it very smart
man oh yeah
mine fury says the metaverse remember
demolition man from the mid 90s adult
activity was banned and lovemaking
required a vr headset how prescient in
retrospect
ugh prescient has never sounded more
seedy than the way you yeah i don't like
that
i don't feel good about it
all right roberto lara says lex had the
same discussion with mark zuckerberg
about how we'll represent ourselves on
the metaverse a recommendable podcast
you get to see the android mark versus
the robot lex that is interesting yeah
p ph uh ph gamer says omg at tim you
need to watch ghost in the shell
standalone complex it was eerie where it
went but there was an episode where a
stalker put on a cyber suit body of her
lover and tried to kill him i have seen
ghost in the shell stand alone complexes
but it's been i think 20 years or you
know close to that so i should re-watch
it but amazing series i love that
opening song by origa as well good music
all right matt r says if you like sharp
things in a business that doesn't hate
anyone try my brother's mall shop anime
armory dot square dot sight they have
they have a sharp zelda prop for you
we have the you saw the master swords i
saw the master sword i wanna i wanna
sharpen it
well yeah you've gotta sharpen it but i
don't think it's made of a real i don't
know how you're going to kill ganon with
a dull master silver arrow it's magic i
suppose
eric constance says ian quote i'm a huge
star trek tng fan doesn't know what best
of both worlds is shaking my head well
true i wanna i just wanna in defense of
ian it's been so long since i've
actually done a watch through of tng
it's been i think like seven years
that i probably am gonna you know i'd
mess up next i went through like uh a
year phase where i watched every episode
night after night or like a five or six
month thing but i didn't catch the names
of any of them
i'm old and watched them in real time
nice oh i mean i watched them when i was
a little kid my dad would put it on the
couch you saw them all in real time oh
wow yeah i i very vividly remember i was
on a a band trip i was a saxophone
player and i was in in the high school
band and we were down in austin texas in
an embassy suites and everybody was
going to go out and hang out for the
night but it was the night of the
final series finale of the next
generation
and so i stayed inside and watched
picard and q mix it up and everybody
else went out and yeah
he was a great character man yeah
all right bn says i've heard star trek
creator gene roddenberry was a confirmed
atheist who hated organized religion the
acronym borg stands for bigoted
organized religious groups any thoughts
said i don't believe i don't believe the
borg thing but he wasn't roddenberry was
an atheist yeah i think that's right
yeah um in the original series
they're less heavy handed about it but
then in next gen picard says some things
which are like more overtly secular but
uh uh bigoted wasn't used as frequently
in that context back then as it is today
so i'm not sure that i believe that
you know
all right what is it uh mixed up says
jeremy asked him to sing a song on the
members only segment truth be told i
thought it was going to say something
about jerry me singing what cause you
have a hit song i think right yeah
together again oh yeah sing us the song
you're the beanie man yeah what there
you go that's right
all right we'll grab a couple more here
actually uh
t gray says when dallas sonia was on is
that
am i pronouncing that
was on tim cast ireland he said daily
wire needs to break into the sci-fi
genre jeremy would you prefer to read a
treatment sooner or a screen screenplay
later i have studied up on your stuff
and have something i think fits the
daily wire yeah one of the real
challenges is how to take submissions
yeah you know when you talk about how uh
we make a lot of money and there are all
these rules about how we can spend it uh
the rules around copyright
and pitches unsolicited and particular
pitches are so absurd if you send a
screenplay to me i will not be able to
read it legally if you mail it to me i
will not be able to open the mail if you
email it to me i'll have to delete it
without opening it and show my attorney
that i've deleted it because uh the
studios for years and years and years
have paid settlement money to people who
say uh you know jurassic park that was
my i had the idea that we should make a
movie with dinosaurs in it 24 years ago
and i pitched it to a guy who at that
time worked in the concession stand at
an amc theater or whatever uh and and
that's a very lucrative business and so
i'll just tell you that for me
uh one of the great stories of my life
this guy roderick taylor the falconer
who's had a bunch of songs he had seven
records with david geffen back in the
70s and 80s and then he became a great
screenwriter he he wrote on tv then he
had a feature film with jody foster
called the brave one that you may recall
and rod told me this great story one
time where his father was at a
retirement community or something down
in florida and called him hey dad how's
it going
rod i i need to put you on the phone
with my friend you don't have any
friends dad what are you talking about
no no my my friend my friend who works
at the front desk of the old folks home
he's like all right dad put him on the
phone guy gets on phone he goes hey i've
got this great idea for a screenplay and
rod said
i don't need your idea
i'm a professional writer it's basically
he was he was in glengarry glen ross uh
i don't i'm a professional writer i have
had every idea ideas are not what's
missing what's missing is execution and
this is a great lesson
your screenplay may be terrific your
idea may be great it is all execution at
every step and uh i wish that i could
short shortcut for you how to get your
screenplay to me as especially if it's
well executed but you just have to keep
executing and we have to find ways
around these really prohibitive laws
that make it almost impossible because
if i hear your idea and it's bad
it still puts me in a position where i
can't make a good version of that idea
or some other idea that's sort of
tangentially related to that idea 20
years from now when i don't even
remember the bad idea that i've heard
can they this can be fixed there are
ways around it but it is very
challenging can they recuse on the mail
i oh i suggest i want no copyright for
this yes and in fact one of the things
that we are talking about doing is
trying to create some sort of digital
submission because in a digital
submission i can make you check the box
before you submit
this is not because i want to steal
people's ideas
not in any way it's because
we
dallas sonja has read
500 scripts for me in the last year
500 scripts
every idea in some germ of every idea
has been present in one of those scripts
so you just can't be in a situation
where 20 years from now you make
something you can't there's no way you
stole someone's idea right you're just
you're doing the work you can't create
those liabilities that again there are
ways around it that's one way i i i've
never uh cared much for
idea i i i've never viewed ideas as
being the most important thing like
you're saying execution is everything
yes and i actually think it's kind of a
cop out too for people like i had this
idea and it's like and you did nothing
with it you did yes so i've been at a
bunch of meetings and uh i learned this
when i was in california from a lot of
people or this is what they told me is
uh
what you're told when you're growing up
poor is never share your ideas because
they'll steal it and what they tell you
when you're rich is
share your idea with everyone you can to
refine it
because if if an investor hears it
they're going to hire you the guy who
thought of it who has the vision and the
passion to do it to to make it because
well trying to find someone else to do
it means you're gonna have someone who's
not driven to do it it's a mistake yeah
so for me for the most part i don't care
if someone steals my ideas you know i'll
i'll talk about my ideas whatever with
anybody and i'll i'm such a firm
believer in execution i'll give away any
idea too
my friend no one's gonna steal it yeah
and that's right most people even if
they knew exactly how to do what you've
done if even if you gave them even if it
were replicable and you gave them the
blueprint on how to replicate it 99.9
percent of people wouldn't exactly even
if you're paying them sometimes like
there's that for i'm blessed with an
amazing team but sometimes like you
could be working on a project with a
group of people or if any of you have
worked a job with with other people who
just were not doing what they were
supposed to it's like you can get orders
from people above you to do a specific
thing and like everyone drops the ball
so the idea that people are just gonna
like take your idea and make it for free
is ridiculous well you know so i've been
in so many meetings pitching ideas and
everything and i've always just been
like here's all of my ideas none of them
have ever been stolen yeah the the issue
you'll learn when it comes to a lot of
investors too because i've sat down with
big investor meetings and they're like
you know we've had conversations about
how people are scared of their ideas
being stolen and they were like the idea
that we'd invest in a random person we'd
hire as opposed to the person who had
the idea is kind of a crazy thought it
can happen if a really dumb person like
a really undriven person who doesn't do
anything puts two and two together and
like that is actually a good idea but
this person can't pull it off i'll tell
you an amazing story when we met with
the high net worth individual who gave
us the the initial capital on which we
built the daily wire
again it was a very small amount of
money compared to the success that we've
driven but we needed it it was an
instrumental moment in our money in our
careers to go raise that money we're
sitting in this giant like bond villain
uh conference room you know i'm sure
there was a shark button that they could
have pressed if they didn't like our
pitch and the high net worth individual
was in the room and some and some other
members of his family were in the room
and ben and i were and caleb were giving
our pitch
and at a certain point one of one of the
high net worth individuals
relatives leaned back in his chair and
he said
you know
people pitch us ideas all the time
a lot of people have come in here and
say they want to build a company that
makes conservative content puts it on
the internet why should we give our
money to you and ben shapiro did not
miss
not not half a second he said
i'm better than they are
execution that's it
um if you go before me and you say
i tell this people all the time
when it comes to sales and pitches
you might get a
someone with no talent but someone who
speaks well like no no ability to build
the machine but they can tell you they
can build the machine and who am i
supposed to trust if someone comes to me
and says i want to build a 3d printer
i'm going to say why should i why should
i fund this and if they say well look to
be honest there are a lot of printers
out there you know i think i can do a
good job but um i i will i will do my
best i'm like okay if some guy comes in
and says listen you want a 3d printer
i'm going to build it it'll be the best
you've ever seen no one can do it better
than me i'll be like all right well
if you don't have the confidence
yourself to do it i can't invest in it
yeah but that being said
go to timcast.com have confidence in us
yes we're gonna have a members only
segment coming up around 11 pm is when
we'll publish it so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and
become a member at timcast.com you can
follow us at tim cast irl basically
everywhere you can follow me at timcast
jeremy do you want to shout anything out
well first of all uh i would promote tim
cass but everybody listening already
knows about it but i really appreciate
you guys having me on the show uh you
know if somebody wants to head over to i
hate harry's dot com they'll get the
shave of their life uh with a jeremy's
razor and we'd love to have your
business over at dailywire.com as well
right on i'm seamus coughlin i create an
animated web series called freedom tunes
if you all want to go check that out we
released a cartoon today and one on
tuesday go over there and subscribe
please and thank you very much ian
crossland for me and crossland.net
seamus can you roll me that red hundreds
you want me to roll you this dice you're
gonna risk it no no i'm not gonna i just
i don't want you to like roll a one in
the shower i haven't known i had a gift
for you it's this red one
oh my god happy birthday to me that was
a 20 minute happy birthday homie you're
like a human being right
there you jerry thank you so much for
coming man hey sheamus yeah ian gave me
a 120-sided dice yeah
well it's different comparison it really
isn't enough i know right
it's terrible anyway i really appreciate
that high note to go out on thank you so
much for coming jeremy i really
appreciate what you guys are doing over
at the daily wire we are having john
madden matt john mattingly on in the
future and andrew clavin as well very
excited to do like this crossover
between the two different companies i am
sarah patrick you can follow me on
twitter at minds.com we will see all of
you over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you